of the house Judiciary Committee I find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the covid-19 pandemic in accordance with
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuing to executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronic this is a public hearing on
Senate bills referred to this committee
with the potential for executive
sessions to be held
throughout we expect to hold our
executive session afternoon at 1:00
which has been SCH please know that
there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
board I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
by the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information will made
available in the house C and through the
electronic calendar on the general rept
website notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and RSA 91a to WR to no
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
271-3600 that's 271 3600 or email
HCS l
.n.
Us in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
aured and
rescheduled we do have a staff me member
who is participating with us today and
that is Brad green he is a committee
researcher please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting will
be taken by roll call
vote we're going to begin the meeting by
taking Ro call attendance when each
member states their presence please also
State whether there's anyone in the room
with you during this meeting which is
required
right
me yes I'm here uh in West Milan
alone representative
Chase representative Chase hi sorry
about that yes I'm here I'm actually in
CMI Florida and I'm here alone sounds
like you're in Florida I am in
Florida sorry I know it's hard to hear
me
represent good morning I'm here in my
home office in New Market and I'm in the
room
alone yes I am present at the
Legislative Office Building
[Music]
301 yes I'm at my home office in Hudson
my wife will be coming and going
throughout the
day representative H um I'm I'm here at
my home office in Durham by
myself
representa
me no I I'm in Temple um in the room
alone but my mom's visiting from
California and May pop in and out
representa
Kenny good morning I am here in my
apartment in Durham uh currently alone
in the room but roommates may be walking
through throughout the day thank you
representative
L good morning I'm here in Manchester at
home and my husband might be in and out
during the day thank you representative
M I'm present here in my Portsmouth in
my home um office and I'm alone good
morning representative CL I'm here in
the L with u fellow colleagues in the
committee good morning I'm in exitor
alone
representative n here in the committee
room representative
burner representative
murer representative
senson good morning I'm here in exitor
I'm alone my spouse and my kids may come
in and out at some point during the day
representative s uh good morning I'm UR
alone
representative home alone in
Belmont representative
Tosh representa
to represent Melvin in the L represent
here in
the
we uh first just note that we welcome
representative n representative today
they have been newly appointed as
substitutes today for representative BR
represent represent
Tri and we're going to begin our
hearings today with Senate Bill
and we will conduct our hearings this
morning note
on Bill 95 there were 102 people who
signed up in support of the bill there
were two people who signed up in
opposition to the bill and there are 12
people who
pre-registered
that the primary sponsor of the Omnibus
Bill has three parts and that sponsor is
Senator
Gary
Senator could you could you raise his
hand yeah could you raise your
hand I
don't also
pre-registering to testify was
Senator she's
there good morning can you all hear me
we
can okay good morning I do hope Senator
Daniels is able to T this morning but um
I'll offer my testimony in the meanwhile
so good morning all of you nice to see
so many of you from my district um for
the record I'm Senator Rebecca perin
quoka from Senate District 21
representing the city of Portsmouth and
the towns of Madbury Lee Durham
Newington New Market and newfields I the
prime sponsor of part one of SB 95 FN
relative to remote access to meetings
under RSA
91a through emergency order 12 Governor
senu enabled public bodies to continue
to meet during the covid-19 pandemic
with the modification of the right to no
rules to allow remote meetings part one
of sb95 FN is the codification of that
emergency order all of us have taken
part in these remote meetings we're
doing so right now in addition to
ensuring stay stfe and healthy during
the pandemic remote meetings also allow
many more people to take part in their
government we've seen during public
hearings this session that many more
people to remote hearings and would nor
normally be able to and this is not to
mention the many more elected officials
who have an Avenue to participate
without worrying about child care as
much or needing to travel during this
unusual time passing part one of sb95
will ensure that governments on all
levels City towns are able to continue
offering expanded access and
transparency even after the covid-19
pandemic and the state of emergency
end
um you know I'll be happy to answer any
questions I do add that we've worked
closely with the New Hampshire Municipal
Association on the language of this bill
and that originally both Senator James
and I had brought um separate parts of s
sp95 so there was originally a part one
and a part two we've worked together to
combine those two parts so that what the
bill that's in front of you now um
represents the combined efforts of the
Senate to find something that everybody
could work with and so um this bill
passed on the senate floor 24 to nothing
um and I welcome your questions I know
that
uh cell Johnson from New Hampshire
Municipal association's here as well
today are there questions for the
senat
yes thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question so I'm looking
through the bill and it it scratches out
all of the language you pertaining to
the requirements for having an emergency
and things of this nature are there any
um
requirements uh to allow this to take
place or is it just the body on its own
can just decide that this is the best
way to do its own
business uh yes sir thank you very much
for the question representative it it
was um in the Senate part of compromise
that we made that it needs to be the
governing body of each municipality that
makes the decision whether to hold um
remote meetings so the way that it's
structured now is that um remote
meetings can continue in their current
state until each municipality has the
opportunity to take that vote at which
time the authority has turned over to
them and in addition I think you'll see
that we added um two things into this
legislation one is um a study commission
which should meet later this year to
make sure that we're correcting you know
or improving the process in any way
possible and we added a sunset Clause so
that um you know we need to make sure we
have legislation on this next year that
will either extend the for
municipalities to do this if if a lot of
them take it up or where this right will
end um after the legislative session
next
year there other questions for the
sen yes represent
well thank you very much Mr chair first
of all I just say we got email from um
Senator daniels's Aid so he's trying to
log in so um might want to somebody
might want to call Deb Marton mik my
question is is um are there any um
requirements here for uh recording the
meetings when it's possible which uh
something that was not done here in the
house or the that was not done here in
the house house at all until like uh you
know until till 2020 but which is proven
very useful and is there any uh anything
in here talking about how the uh
recording should be uh
preserved yes thank you representative
Horan um there is no requirement that uh
meetings be recorded there is only um
the requirement that if the meeting is
to be held remotely that there is audio
access available remotely there is
always the option of course that a
municipality could choose to record but
unfortunately um you know we just didn't
feel that that was um that that was
something that the all municipalities
would be able to to meet at this time
okay
thanks thank
you guess my my only question that I had
when I read the bill
was the first the first part then the
third
part again is establishing committee to
look at having the remote
meetings seems like it's sort of like a
a ready fire a approach by doing the
legislation first and studying
afterwards yes thank you chairman Garden
so um and and I'm to how it it may come
across a little confusing so the intent
is that because our municipalities are
currently operating this way you know to
the extent they have decided to or been
able to our hope is not to disturb their
business but rather let them continue in
the way they've operating or chosen to
operate for this time however we also
want to make sure that if there are
opportunities to improve the procedure
that's been underway for for example um
there was a conversation about whether
roll call votes are necessary for every
vote over Zoom people had different
opinions about that that would be
something that could be raised in the
study commission to ensure that um if we
are going to continue with remote
meetings into next year and Beyond in
any capacity that we're doing so in the
best way possible so the idea was to
sort of you know
concurrently allow current operations to
continue while you know taking a look at
how we can improve that and then make
sure that we we bring um the results of
both of those things back to the
legislature next year if we'd like to
remove the sunset or if we'd like to
make improvements to the
statute thank you Mr chair and thanks
for my followup question I just you
mentioned in your testimony that there's
a sunset clause on this that the purpose
of the study committee is to look at it
um is that is is a sunset clause in part
three of the of the bill I'm just trying
to find
it yes exactly so
[Music]
um I'm just looking at everything so in
section in part
[Laughter]
one
three
um yes there's a sunset class and and my
um my is as I've just so I'm going I may
need Senator Daniels to join us and and
just um fully answer that piece because
I know he worked closely with his caucus
um on that but but as I've described it
so far that's you know the effect of
legislation and that's the date in
section three of part
one all right thank you thank you very
much thank you any other questions for
the see thank you for your testim
[Music]
today thank you very much I also see in
the attendees looks like Senator
[Music]
Ray sen
GR
hit the button here uh good morning I am
James Gray uh District Six Senator uh
covering Alton Barnstead
Gilton
Rochester and
Farmington um my part of this uh bill is
part two um violations of privacy um the
uh this was brought to me by both the
chiefs of police in summersworth and r
Chester and the County Attorney uh that
currently under the statute for
violations of privacy where uh pictures
and other things are being taken of
people in violation of their privacy uh
is not allowed to be charged any higher
than a misdemeanor and they would like
the
opportunity um if this is an ongoing
thing with a particular individual to
increase that penalty and that's
what this bill does is that if they
believe that it is warranted it can be
elevated to a class B
felony questions foror
gr question um thank you Mr chair um
thank you for taking my question Senator
gray now how do um these violations of
privacy where there's a um kind of like
sexual um violation how do those work
with the sex offenders registry are
people who have found guilty of invading
privacy um set at tier one tier two or
tier three thank you um that would be a
decision for the courts uh I do not know
the the exact answer to that um again I
don't think that if you're convicted of
a misdemeanor anything happens but um I
certainly am not the authority on that
thank
you and Senator
Daniels able to
connect
representative we are currently working
with him to make sure he's able to get
on to the
meeting you're not connected
yet that's correct he's not connected at
the
moment then we'll call upon other people
who here on the
list Peter
Miller are people who
pre-register
Mr Miller if you raise
your Linda
Bundy
you should be
there is Bundy can you hear
us you need to
unmute you're still
muted I'm sorry
good morning chairman Gordon and members
of the committee I'm Linda Bundy and I'm
from antrum I'm speaking in support of
sb95 the pandemic pandemic has shown a
light on inequities and oversights in
our communities but it has also
illuminated new ways of working and
participating in society video
conferencing tools such as Zoom
exemplify one of these changes
in our personal professional and Civic
lives we have quickly become accustomed
to communicating and interacting with
others while staying at
home citizen participation in
legislative hearings has been open to a
much wider population people who are
elderly disabled or health impaired can
now observe and testify on bills
important to them transportation to
conquered or time limitations no longer
have to be impediments to
participation I support the creation of
a legislative committee to study remote
access to meetings and make re
recommendations My Hope Is that the
committee will recommend the
continuation of this access New
Hampshire Prides itself on having a
citizen legislature with significant
input from
constituents continuation of remote
access to legislative hearings will move
participation into the 21st century by
assuring accessibility for the largest
number of citizens thank you for your
time thank you are there any questions
from
Miss again thank you for your testimony
today thank
you next person would be
Tod
ah morning Mr C good morning um my name
is Todd selig I'm the administrator for
the town of Durham New Hampshire and I'm
accompanied this morning by with Wayne
Burton who is the uh Town Council Vice
chairman here in Durham um I believe
last evening representative Margie Smith
shared with you uh the Durham Town
Council resolution
20219 which was passed unanimously by a
90 vote last night endorsing
sb95 just a few thoughts for you on this
bill uh first at the outset of the
pandemic we were very concerned about
how virtual meetings would work uh we
put a lot of time and effort and
investment into that and ultimately
they've worked well Durham has a very
long tradition of equity and inclusion
and transparency so we wanted to give
our residents the fullest access to our
public meetings and local officials
during this pandemic time over time our
residents have become very familiar with
the platform um in fact we had a
resident last night at our council
meeting who at the outset of the
pandemic struggled greatly to figure out
how to unmute how to talk into the
microphone where to look last night this
individual was right there in the
meeting participating actively and this
was an individual who was old older in
years so it was very successful some uh
General benefits uh that I wanted to
highlight for you first is um we believe
that residents gain better access to
public meetings with this virtual option
the second is um virtual meetings are
just plain more sustainable there's no
need to get in the car and drive to the
town hall or in your case drive to
conquer you can participate virtually
which is positive third item is that um
it increases participation residents who
have disabilities illnesses child care
or Elder Care issues or residents or
board members who are traveling can
participate virtually which has been
very beneficial the fourth point is uh
inclement weather no problem uh with
zoom you can zoom into the meeting and
there's no need to to Brave the elements
and take a risk on icy roads in the
winter or if there's a a severe storm
that comes through and finally uram
we've had no issues of fraud or abuse
locally it's worked very well so I just
wanted to close by saying that that you
in this era of trying to increase and
drive Public participa public
participation in local issues with dual
career couples and many demands and
distractions on people's time we believe
virtual meetings um is an excellent
additional uh uh uh tool in our
proverbial local toolbox in the public
process we believe that uh this virtual
platform is a public benefit here in
Durham and for the state and we hope
we're able to continue to use it moving
forward thank you very
much be happy to answer any
questions
questions see none thank you for your
testimony next person representative
Gordon Senator Daniels is now in the
meeting so we would
call
good morning members of the committee
this is Senator Daniels district 21
excuse me District 11 representing the
towns of ammer Milford Wilton and marac
I am the prime sponsor of Senate Bill 95
I apologize I couldn't find out how to
unmute to begin with so I've been been
uh trying to get in for 20 minutes um so
the uh the bill that before you that
came amended from from the Senate uh
merged part one and part two which both
had to do with virtual
meetings uh and we use part two as the
base uh for bringing that forward uh the
bill authorizes the public body to allow
one or more members to participate in
the meeting virtually uh to hold a
virtual meeting where one or more
members are not in the same location the
meeting must comply with the statute uh
in the right to no laws uh if not all
members are at the same location Public
Access must be by telephone uh and it
can be by additional um media means
although it's not required as towns may
not possess those means uh if the
meeting is virtual public notice must be
given on how the public can access the
meeting just as is is now the notice to
the public uh shall be shall the excuse
me the notice to the public shall
provide instructions on how to alert the
public body if there are problems with
accessing the meeting and whether or not
the meeting is virtual all participants
must be able to clearly communicate with
each other if the meeting is virtual all
members of the meeting must identify the
location from which it partip ating uh
if the meeting is virtual all votes must
be taken by roll call and um if the
public is unable to access the meeting
the meeting shall be adjourned so you
see it it's very much like what we are
doing now what we've been living with
for the past few months uh just to
quickly go
through the bill uh because it was
amended in the
Senate uh so that the bill will take
effect upon passage uh regardless of
whether or not the state of emergency
exist and the continuation of virtual
meeting Authority uh will continue until
July 1st
2022 um a study committee is
established uh which will be effective
60 days after passage to assess the
virtual meeting policy uh enacted to
monitor the practices and note any
problems that are encountered that study
committee that study committee will rep
will re produce a report on November 1st
2021 and then be discontinued uh based
on the study committee's report and
recommendations uh we can then bring
forth legislation next year that will
either address the deficiencies and
repeal the July 1st
2022 date of this bill or or just repeal
the uh date if there are no
deficiencies uh if nothing is done the
authority
will uh will be discontinued and
repealed on July 1st um I know one of
the parts of the bill that has been a
little bit confusing for people is part
uh excuse me section two of part one
you'll see in there the the the language
is pretty much almost a duplicate of uh
part one excuse me section one of that
bill but I guess that's the way that it
had to be drafted so that part two is
the original language that is now in law
so if uh it's
repealed uh then it goes back to that
language in part two and with that I'll
conclude my testimony apologize if I
repeated a lot of what people have said
but we'll be willing to take any
questions any questions for
the yes president M so I'm sorry
representative Daniels but for the part
you're testifying right before the study
committee you were garbled for us here
in the committee room I don't know about
the folks remotely so um so if you could
go back before you were talking about
the study committee and just repeat what
you were saying about part one and how
it would be implemented because you were
garbled here in the
room okay uh yes um just just to let you
know how things will happen is that uh
the bill will take effect upon passage
but uh it there is a date in there will
where it will be repealed on July 1st
2022 so essentially you know we we will
be able to do the virtual U meetings for
about a year but about uh 60 days after
passage a study committee is created to
monitor uh the the experiences of people
using these virtual meetings and they'll
be taking taking note of any
deficiencies and come out with a report
on November 1st of
2021 uh next year and next session we
will be able to take the result of th
that report and we can fix or tweak uh
as needed the experiences that we've
been having or people have been having
with the virtual meetings so we will
have the option of either uh addressing
the any deficiencies that come up and
then repealing the July 1st date to
allow virtual meetings to
continue or we if there are no
deficiencies we can just file a bill to
take off the repeal date uh if nothing
is done then the bill will automatically
be repealed on July 1st
further question yeah F thank you for
for taking my follow-up question so I'm
I I think you're right I am a little bit
confused with with part one between part
one of part one and part two of part one
so if I go and I look at part one of
part one it pretty much says physical
location is not required and there's no
restrictions around that but if I look
at part two of part one
uh going on to page
three uh Roman page page three line
three accept an emergency acum of the
public body shall be physically present
so
um so are those in conflict or am I just
reading it
wrong no it's it's very confusing and
actually I I had to check with
legislative services to make sure there
wasn't a problem uh section two of part
one that part that you just read is the
original is that is the language in
statute
now okay and if you look on on page
three on uh line
26 okay you'll you'll you'll see that
says section two of part one of this act
shall take effect July 1st 2022
essentially what that says is that on
July 1st 2022 we will revert back to the
current language which is section two so
that that's the sunset Clause we were
looking for okay I got that is that is
the sun yes that is
correct so just one last followup so
then if this was not to pass and the
emergency order ends that basically
terminates the ability for anybody to do
remote meetings is that my understanding
that I believe that is
correct okay thank you sure yeah and I
would I would just add that uh you know
I I heard a little bit of Mr celik's um
comments and I would agree with them I'm
I'm a selectman in the town of Milford
and uh when when we had in-person
meetings uh before Co started we'd be
lucky if we had maybe three or four
people show up to those meetings uh we
now have somewhere between 35 and 40
that regularly tune in and while while
we have uh cable Access TV those on the
other end could only watch what was
going on they couldn't participate they
can now participate by calling calling
in so it really is a win-win situation
because it it helps us as Selectmen to
educate the public as to what's going on
but it also helps the public because
they can participate in the
meetings any other questions
for
sing thanks for your testimony today
thank you
folks next person would be
[Music]
G good morning chairman Gordon and
members of the House Judiciary Committee
my name is Jean Bowden and I am the Town
Administrator in Belmont New Hampshire
in March of 2020 the ability to conduct
municipal government changed
dramatically catching many of us in
smaller communities unprepared to deal
with the safer at home restrictions and
the reality that remote meetings and
online services were going to be
necessary we had to purchase equipment
and software options that would allow
our boards staff and committees to meet
securely the governor's uh the creation
of the governor's office for emergency
relief and response which assisted in
funding our equipment and software
upgrades was vital and truly provided us
the town the ability to continue to meet
our residents needs my select board was
skeptical initially that the public
would accept the remote meeting option
they were unsure that planning and
zoning boards would be able to provide
adequate plan review and feedback
through a remote process however over
the course of the following months Our
Town boards and committees became
accustomed to the process and we found
that public participation increased we
successfully deliberated the development
of the 2021 budget with a budget
committee remotely and each member of
the committee felt the process went
smoothly we have resumed our in-person
meetings um as of this month however we
are continuing to provide a um a link
via Zoom for anyone not wishing to
attend in person and we hope to continue
this option going forward we urge
members of the committee to support the
bill as proposed and I thank you for
your time and I'm happy to answer any
questions you any
questions see again thank you for your
testimony thank
you I know that we have a few more
people to testify but everybody who
signed up to testify has signed up in
favor of
representative Gilman Julie
Gilman thank you chairman Gordon and
members of the committee I'm
representative uh Julie Gilman uh
Rockingham 18 uh representing exiter I
am also a select woman in exitor and
have been since 2007 so I have seen this
change in our uh
meeting U method really grow in the
participation I don't want to go into
the details that everyone else has I
agree with Senator Perkins quoka uh Mr
selig and and uh Senator Daniels uh we
have seen a great amount of
participation and I can say over 14
years great um and it's the visual as
well as verbal aspect is uh is much more
uh successful in our conf in our um
conversations um one thing I would like
to say about the larger participation is
that uh we see more participation by
people with families because the town
cannot find a substantial or or healthy
way to do child care during meetings of
like the planning board or the various
boards and commissions so we don't get
the people that are affected uh for a
longer range of time because they are
younger and perhaps cannot have a spouse
that can watch children while they're
participating in a meeting uh so that's
one of the big pluses for me is that we
can have a greater participation of
volunteers not just the general public
um And in regards to the questions about
the of 91a I would recommend an
amendment to uh require written minutes
as we do now uh because those would be
available in perpetuity and not depend
on the method of recording that we're
using um and the other is
uh the Privacy um whether or not people
want to be seen on camera uh that we um
have an option to ask for permission at
the time that they're participating as
in this meeting you could ask me do I
want to uh have my face on the screen or
would I like to remain uh just as a a
member participating uh
remotely um and the last thing is about
the
transportation and as you know one of
your members is in kissamee Florida uh
so you would not have a a larger
participation in your committee without
the option of being remote for me um I
have epilepsy and the medication I take
doesn't allow me to drive so I would not
be in conquered to be at this meeting
unless representative Paige or or
Simpson uh gave me a ride and then I
would be subject to your um calendar and
would have to stay as all day or all
morning as you are uh depending on the
schedule uh and and so that goes for all
the members of the public that would
like to speak uh you know they can't
make take a day off to go to conquer
they take can't take a morning off to go
to conquer um and I think that we really
um it's very positive result when you
can either see people or hear from them
directly rather than the bazillion
emails that we get on the various bills
of
interest and I think that is it I don't
want to take up all your uh all your
time I would recommend that all uh votes
be made by roll call if uh you choose to
stay in a remote uh fashion yeah I me
and that is it thank you very much and
I'm willing to take any questions
yes meet myself thank you much Mr chair
thank you much representative and select
uh woman Gilman um something that's
created some controversy here in the
house is that uh you have to have your
camera on when you're doing the roll
call vote but my correct understand that
that's not Universal with all bodies who
because some of them have been doing you
know um all bodies to have remote votes
and um so that
uh does that in your opinion is that is
that something so um you have any
opinion on that
issue yes I would I would agree with you
that um as we do here in the house that
if you're participating member uh that
your face be on screen because the the
as as well as the roll call vote um the
members of the public have to see who is
participating in the meeting and how and
you know how and where you are so yeah
agree with
that any other questions for
representative
Gilman see none thank you for your
testimony today thank
you the next uh person would be Jill
Collins
hell Miss
Collins Miss Collins are you
there seems like we're having difficulty
with that
connection so
what
doesn't doesn't indicate that she's
muted but we can't hear her for some
reason
okay why don't we move on we'll come
back to miss
Collins Louise
Spencer hello Miss Spencer hello thank
you um thank you chairman Gordon for
having me here and also to the members
of the committee so I am here to speak
in support
of uh s sp95 specifically Those portions
of the bill that that speak to allowing
um remote participation in
meetings um I am uh co-founder of a
group called The Kent Street Coalition
which is an all volunteer Grassroots
advocacy
organization uh I speak here on my own
behalf but you maybe many of you have
seen us at in the halls of the State
House back when we could do that and the
whole purpose of our group is really to
promote engagement citizen engagement in
in our democracy
particularly um at the state level so
and this is really part of a proud
tradition in New Hampshire of robust
citizen engagement
um
and I'm sorry I don't I was just seeing
if I could make take off my um my
picture and make myself live but I don't
see how to do that but um anyway we have
a proud tradition here in New Hampshire
of Citizen engagement and this bill
really UND underscores that commitment
and with a willingness to incorporate
new and modern tools and um while we
often were're at the State House many of
us as retired people who live here and
conquered we were well aware of those
who were not able to join us those who
were working who have disabilities who
were taking care of sick family members
or children those who couldn't drive or
otherwise who didn't have access to
transportation and while we would do our
best to represent them and their voices
it's obviously not the same as people
being able to uh be there and speak and
participate themselves um there have not
been many benefits of covid but learning
that we could find new ways for people
to participate in government was
certainly one of those positives and I
think that we see evidence of that here
this morning a number of people have
mentioned you know that they would not
have been able to be here but for remote
access we also see it on the signin
sheet where in times past you know maybe
there would have been five or 10 names
on those blue sheets um 50 would have
been cons considered a really large
number um here we have have over hundred
um citizens who have added their voice
and weighed in on this process so we
hope that the study committee will
um will will meet and see that this is
something that enriches our Civic life
and that we'll figure out ways to make
this a permanent part of how we do self
government and self-governance because
um we benefit when we can hear from all
the voices who make up our community so
um with that I Echo the words of of much
of what was said here today and
particularly value
those those people who are you know
participating as elected members um of
City governments and town governments
and very appreciative of their
service willingness to be flexible in
incorporating this uh new approach into
the work that they do I I it just speaks
again to
the the great service that that so many
people in this state do whether it's
serving on a in the legislature serving
in local government so thank you thank
thank thank you for your Tes there uh
representative syia did you have a
question do thank you Mr chairman and uh
thank you for taking my question um and
I'm sorry to do this but this will be a
would you believe that uh as a
legislator I would value those uh uh
signatures on the the blue sheet uh
quite more highly than 100 uh phone in
from all across the
country um May I answer that yes yeah
yes so I one of my big concerns is that
we find a way through the remote
signings to make it very clear who is
signing in as a um as a New Hampshire
voter um or a New Hampshire resident
versus people signing in from across the
country I I think it's really um my
interest in this is really the ability
of New Hampshire citizens and New
Hampshire res residents to participate
in self-governance so I would like to
see those those blue sheets um whether
they be remote or whether they be in
person really providing opportunities
for people to list their town and make
it clear whether they are here to
participate in New Hampshire
self-governance or whether they are here
weighing in with an opinion from out of
state thank you for answering my
question and I uh really value seeing
your face in the uh legislative office
building along with others who are
willing to do the hard work of showing
up thank you thank you representative
Horgan need to unmute
yourself unmute buttons are probably
something we will we want if we ever get
back iners meeting some something that
was an issue well probably more so at
the at the legislature just because the
way the L is set up which isn't case
with zoom is um that you know the room
has essentially uh has enough room room
for everybody so it's not not a question
to cramy into a small small hearing room
so how do you uh so you think that has
changed you think that is you think the
fact that we have have like a you know a
virtual room that has enough room for
everybody you think that's changed the
uh just sort of like uh who shows up at
the who shows up at the hearings and um
and and so for and like just s like how
they how they
go I'm sorry I'm trying to make sure I
understand the question oh just W um
just wonder if the makeup the if if you
found it the make of the hearings is
perhaps changed somewhat just by the uh
fact not just by the fact that people
don't that uh just we're we're now
meeting in rooms that are big enough to
fit everyone who shows up and we have
like a blue sheet that's right there at
the website rather than sort of get in
in the corner of the room that you have
to fight a bunch of people off to get to
so if you
found I'm sorry um yes definitely we see
a much more diverse um group of people
who are able to be in those rooms in
those virtual rooms um in terms of you
know the people that can't take off a
full day from work but can take off an
hour or people who can be home with
their children um people who have health
related concerns such as epilepsy or
other reasons those people are now able
to be present in the rooms I I would
like to just step back to something that
representative Silva said I agree there
is also great value in inperson
engagement and interaction and so I
don't see this as a substitute for for
that um in fact I think it's one of the
things right now we all are very much
missing because we know that when you
can um you know say hi to somebody
across the room or maybe in the
cafeteria share a cup of tea or have
those moments it helps to break down
some of the polarization that
unfortunately we're dealing with right
now so I also think it does show a great
deal of commitment for those who are
able to come to the state house and
participate in person my concern is
primarily for those people who that
simply is not an option and there are
many many people who fit that category
and I wouldn't want to assume that
they're any less committed to to the
legislative process and to engaging in
government than I than I am who you know
where I happen to be able-bodied have
transportation live fairly locally um I
wouldn't want to make assumptions about
those folks who aren't able to be here
in
person great thank you thank you Mr
chair and and thank you for taking my
question so we did hear a lot of
testimony so far about the enhanced
participation but one of the things that
the bill does in addition to allowing
individual members uh to participate
remotely the bill also allows for the
waving of a physical location all
together so in that situation um you
know as a person who's trying to you
know Drive engagement there might be
people that are on the fringes that
maybe don't have access to technology or
whatever but because there's no physical
location whatsoever while other people
have increased opportunity for
participation maybe those people have
reduced opportunity for participation so
as a person who works to to drive
engagement how would you approach that
kind of
scenario I I thank you for that question
question and I think you make a very
good point again this is all about
removing whatever barriers exist to full
participation in our demogra democratic
form of government and we know for
example that Broadband is an issue in
the North Country um and we also know
that that some people just quite frankly
are better suited to in-person location
so I would favor whenever possible
having a a hybrid model
um I think that that's one of the things
that the committee would be well advised
to to look at and um I would you know
hesitate to move into a system of you
know where it's all remote all the time
there may be reasons on occasion where
where they a physical location doesn't
make sense whether it be due to weather
or another health emergency or something
of that sort but in General personally I
would absolutely favor having the option
for people to be able to show up in
person thank you and to remove whatever
barriers that prevent that um as you
mentioned you
know in terms of any technological
barriers and I I would hope that any
physical spaces that we do have that we
make sure that those are fully
accessible um so that you know if
someone with a disability um wants to
come in person that there are things
like wheelchair ramps or you know or
other things that don't get in the way
or that promote access and that don't
don't create barriers for people with
disabilities for example thank you for
your testimony
today and the next person to testify
would be Kate
Corgan
good morning uh Mr chairman and members
of the Judiciary Committee uh my name is
Kate Horan I serve as the executive
director of the New Hampshire
Association of counties I won't repeat
what others have said I will just simply
state that the association does support
this bill um in regards to the
electronic meetings we think it's uh a
smart way to do it uh we were involved
with Senator Daniels and Senator Perkins
quoka in drafting the legislation
um especially around the sunset
provision and the study committee uh we
have seen increased participation in
County meetings and we don't believe
that covid is going any away anytime
soon so just giving us that extra
flexibility for a year while we look to
see if things uh how things can be
improved to increase participation in
the future uh we think is a a strong way
to approach this and I'm happy to take
any questions are there any questions
from Zan again thank you for your
testimony thank you Ryan
Donnelly hello thank you can you hear me
you can excellent thank you again for
the record my name is Ryan Donnelly I'm
an abuy coordinator with Granite State
independent living GSL is a Statewide
nonprofit organization that Advocates
and provides services for seniors and
people with disabilities who wish to
remain independent in their homes and
communities and I'm speaking to you
today in support of
sb95 and I'll try not to repeat anything
that's already been said but I do want
to emphasize that remote access to
public meetings benefits all New
Hampshire City citizens who wish to
engage with their government and
community and even more so for seniors
and people with disabilities who often
face significant barriers to
participating in person such as lack of
public and accessible Transportation
need for personal care services and
compromised health for many the only way
they can attend and participate in
public hearings meetings and briefings
is remotely via phone video streaming
and video
conferencing this technological ability
to connect with their government and
Community makes the difference between
being heard and not being heard for many
seniors and people disabilities in New
Hampshire with this in mind we hope that
the members of this committee will chose
to support s sp95 and allow for
continued remote access to public
meetings in our state thank
you any questions from Mr
Don seeing n thank you for your
testimony today thank you next person
would be uh natch
grades thank you Mr chair this is n
Grace of the New Hampshire Municipal
Association we do support this bill like
the association of counties we were
involved in assisting Senator Daniels
Senator Perkins quoka and the other
sponsors in the Senate on this bill um I
won't repeat what you've what you've
heard today um you've heard a lot of
support across the board from various
organizations um including Municipal
organizations and I think they pretty
clearly explained why we support this
bill um the only thing I would like to
address is there was a comment made
about uh an a proposal for an amendment
requiring minutes
uh minutes are already required for any
public meeting this bill would not
change that so whether a meeting is held
remotely or in person minutes would be
required I'm happy to take questions any
questions
for yes attorney MC uh representative MC
Beth
sorry thank you Mr chair um and thank
you um Mr gays for taking my question an
earlier representative mentioned I think
the counties that um Lo elected
representatives were also grateful this
for this opportunity because they felt
like they could educate the public and
you know there were I guess they said
they were getting 35 people
participating as opposed to three or
four and that hadn't occurred to me
before that so I'm just wondering are
are your members are you know seeing
that too that it's not just the input
from the public but it's also a way to
educate the public and you know bring
them around that that's correct um so
I've spoken to probably 20 or 30
municipalities over the past year um
that have just spontaneously said how
much they' like remote meetings um
mainly because of that public
participation you know as you heard from
Senator Daniels you went from having
three four five people who normally
attend to 30 or 40 um huge increases in
participation people who don't normally
participate whether they be elderly
whether they be disabled whether may be
parents with young children um across
the board there there are a lot of
things to like about the ability to
participate remotely um and people can
actually learn what their local
government is doing make sure that they
know what their local government is
doing and as appropriate hold those
officials accountable in the voting
booth thank you very much representative
mlan thank you Sharon just just a just a
quick question Mr Grace with with your
membership how do you see um use of the
remote breaking down currently do you
see most people using hybrid approaches
do you see um a heavy use of fully
remote I guess amongst your membership
what what do you see is the kind of
breakdown currently I think it's very
tailored to what municipality you're
talking about so more rural areas with
less internet access are much less
likely to use remote meetings simply
because they understand it's more
difficult for people to participate
including members of the board and
members of the public at the same time
um you know very connected communities
especially those along the i93 Bor i93
Corridor in Southern New Hampshire more
likely to use them um simply because
that's that's what they can do it also
relates to I think um any sort of
concerns that they have in their
communities about covid you know as
you've as you've looked at the map over
the past year I'm sure you've seen some
communities are more more affected than
others um and that's certainly something
that's been taken uh under consideration
by Municipal officials making these
decisions thank you any other questions
attorney
grav seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank you Mr chair we're
gonna go back and give Jill Collins
another try if we can if we can
connect
can you hear me now we can good okay
sorry I had a little technical
difficulty there um I'm Jill Collins I'm
with the town of Hinsdale and I'm the
Town Administrator and thank you for
allowing me to speak this morning um
virtual meetings have become essential
to the town of Hinsdale we've been doing
virtual meetings for the past year at
first we started off um just having
remote meetings but we did open up uh to
what you would call hybrid meetings
where the board is a majority of the
board is present as far as the select
board is present and the planning board
um has has gone pretty much um present
also um and the virtual meetings have
been really well with working um with
the public um it has increased our
numberb of of participation we're
allowed to actually uh share documents
over the screen with the public that are
being acted on by board members um and I
and I don't want to repeat what
everybody else has said
um but I I I do really enjoy having I'm
the zoom person so I set up the zoom
meetings for everybody um so I really do
enjoy having the zoom meetings because
of the fact that we are getting the
participation um we do record the
meetings and we also do minutes of all
our meetings um so those are some of the
questions that came out that I could
answer for you um with that being said
if you have any questions please
ask any questions for Miss Collins
San thank you for your testimony thank
you uh that concludes the list of people
who pre-registered to speak here today
is there anyone else who wishes to speak
here today that has something to add we
haven't heard
perhaps Asma
whoi hi can you hear me we can yeah
thank you so much for allowing me to
speak today uh my name is asile honei
I'm the movement politics director for
rights and democracy in New Hampshire
and I'm just calling in to just um speak
and say that I'm in favor of
sb95 uh because I support more access to
Civic engagement by the public I live in
Lebanon New Hampshire and it's in our
best interest to have remote possibility
for people to be able to participate
just to overcome the hurdles that would
keep them from um Coming forth if if
like for example uh time and disability
as being hurdles um when there is a
possibility to give people more access
to
oops that's my
fault could she Muse oh I'm sorry was I
muted I think that was my fault I'm
sorry just justly yeah just whenever
possible it's h when we can give people
access to the Democratic POS uh the
Democratic process the better I think
it's vital that people keep government
in check and this is one way to allow
people to do that so I'm just here to
speak in support of this important bill
that promotes a more democratic process
and the more ways we reach and engage
people the healthier and more democratic
we become thank you so much thank you m
El huni uh just so we can keep our
minutes accurate who do you represent
yes rights and democracy New
Hampshire okay thank you very much are
there any
questions sing none thank you for your
testimony today thank
you and we have Russell Dean who wishes
to
testify okay I believe I'm unmuted now
you are thank you Mr chair and committee
members for the opportunity to speak my
name is Russell Dean and I'm the town
manager and exitor uh we're testifying
in favor of the bill s
sp95 um I just wanted to make a few
quick points uh one is that in the
virtual space uh small meeting rooms
that are undersized for in-person
meetings uh are becoming as large as the
entire town in the virtual space so
that's a money saver for us also with
multiple meetings uh you can attend that
are running concurrently you can attend
remotely so that's a benefit as well and
just the final point is that regionalism
has really been enhanced by the virtual
meeting space uh we did a lot of work on
the Great Bay and that issue and it was
done virtually in a better way than
excuse me than we could have done in
person so just wanted to make those
points and thank you for the chance to
speak and I'll be happy to answer any
questions you any questions for Mr
D seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you and the last person
who has their hand up is Dr Betty
bden hi good morning can you hear me can
oh wonderful thank you so much um and
chairman Gordon and members of the
committee my name is Betty Bogden and I
reside in Chichester I currently serve
um at the pleasure of the New Hampshire
Board of Nursing as the chair of the all
volunteer practice and education
committee we meet monthly and we have
been using Zoom um as our meeting space
what we do as that practice and
education committee is we take concerns
that are submitted to the Board of
Nursing From nurses LPNs lnas RNs and
the general public throughout the state
and we research and we find that
evidence-based practice best model best
practice so that we can better form the
Board of Nursing to make their decisions
um what we see having allowing us to to
utilize this format of Zoom we have the
ability now to have wonderful members
from Lebanon North people that couldn't
attend these meetings when they were in
conquered right because of that drive
down after a long day at work so it's
really opened up that ability to better
represent the state um and eliminating
those geographical
boundaries um I can't really think of
anything I'm in support of everything
everyone else has said and if you have
any questions I'd be happy to take
them are there any questions for Dr
B seeing none thank you for your
testimony
today and that concludes the
testimony on Senate Bill
I don't know if the committee would like
to take just a brief break before we
begin our next
hearing yeah I think what we'll do is
we're just going to take a 10-minute
Break um and uh just to get uh just a
short break and then we'll begin our
hearing on Senate Bill
126 thank you
okay
sh
we reconvene the house Judiciary
Committee and we'll open the hearing on
Senate Bill
126 I just note that there were 56
people who pre-registered in support one
person registered in
opposition and 10 people uh
pre-registered to testify today everyone
who registered to testify registered to
testify in support of the bill there was
no test no we are not expecting any
testimony and opposition today
so with that we'll Begin by calling the
primary sponsor of the bill that's
Senator Perkins
FCA good morning chairman
again good
morning for the record I am Senator
Rebecca Perkins quoka from Senate
District 21 representing the city of
Portsmouth and the towns of Madbury Lee
Durham Newington New market and
newfields I'm the prime sponsor of 126
FN and also the prime sponsor of part
both parts one and two of that
bill part one is intended to provide
some protection to tenants given the
high prevalence of covid related job
loss under statutes tenants have a 7-Day
notice period for non-payment for
eviction after the 7-Day period
landlords often commence eviction
proceedings if they deem this
circumstances to Warrant it simply due
to the amount of time it takes Pi this
bill would simply allow the tenant to
make payment full payment for its rent
and AAR up to the date of the eviction
Hearing in such a case the eviction
proceedings would be ended and the
Tenant could remain in their home it
makes sense for landlords to keep
tenants who can pay and I think any
landlord here today otherwise would tell
you they agree it is extraordinary
situations which cause us to look at
ways we can make some small tweaks to
give each other a little extra room to
do the best we all can this bill does
not extend the time for eviction
overall part two of the bill enables
residents to apply for and receive
rental assistance prior to an eviction
notice being issued this would allow
people to receive help before an
eviction process
begins often when tenants apply for
assistance adding an inspection by the
municipality is an extra step prior to
tenants receiving such assistance which
in turn allows them to pay rent in an
Ideal World such inspection would always
be a check the box requirement but in
cases where repairs are required by L he
or she may need time to make such
Investments and the Tenant is left
without control over the situation
without Aid and potentially without
housing I think we would all agree we
want people to remain in their homes as
it is well known that keeping someone in
their home is a more Humane solution and
allows them to focus on their work and
their
family Mr chairman thank you for the
opportunity to present sb1 126 I'll be
happy to answer any questions you may
have are there any questions for the
senator see none thank you for your
testimony
today and uh Senator
Birdo also signed up to testify today
she is
available
morning
Senator uh good morning um Mr chair I um
had Grant boss was boss he was going to
um interject for me but um I am the um
Prime sponsor of part three and uh just
wanted to run by uh this
um piece of legislation was brought to
me by the um Commission on human rights
uh they do a lot of work for basically
this piece of um this part three brings
the uh State of New Hampshire in line
with the requirements of HUD in the past
what's been happening is at the work
that the Human Rights Commission does uh
has not been um uh the federal
government has not been um
compensating um the Human Rights
Commission for the work they're doing
this piece of legislation will put put
us in line with HUD and therefore allow
the um the Human Rights Commission to
get uh reimbursed from the federal
government and that is basically it um
on the executive director of The Human
Rights Commission will be should be um
speaking a little bit down the road and
she'll go into detail on the
requirements okay thank you are there
any thank you any questions for Senator
berdo seeing none again thank you for
your testimony Senator thank
you
have Elliot
Barry
good morning can you hear me we can
great uh thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee for the record my name
is Elliot Barry I'm the director of
housing Justice at New Hampshire legal
assistance uh it's a pleasure to be back
uh before you especially on a bill where
apparently everybody agrees that it is
the uh prototype win-win
situation uh again just to be really
clear under current current law um as a
number of you know already if a tenant
gets an eviction not they generally have
seven days to pay I'm sorry for
non-payment of rent they basically have
seven days to uh solve that to cure the
non-payment and if they don't um there's
no right to continue to pay and stay
this bill um extends that until the date
of the hearing but it also says that if
the tenant does uh cures the non-payment
after the landlord tenant writ has been
filed the 10 part of the Cure is that
the tenant also has to pay the filing
fee and the service costs associated
with uh that the landlord incurred uh
when uh he he filed the eviction action
uh as was already mentioned that it adds
no time to the process and the great
thing right now is I think a a number of
you probably know that the Federal
federal government has provided uh
millions of dollars to the state uh in
order to help uh tenants who were
adversely affected by covid uh to catch
up on their rent however and I think
it's being administered well but nobody
gets payment within seven days it's
going to take much longer uh and this
will provide the tenant with the time
they need even when covid is over local
welfare administrators and Charities
will get much more time uh to deal with
these emergency situations and again I
think um uh it's it's a pleasure um and
I'm really pleased that there is so much
support for this bill and I don't want
to be presumptuous but I certainly
appreciate the support that I know many
of you will give it and I'd be happy to
answer any questions thank you any
questions for attorney
Barry see none thank you for your
testimony today thank you Nick
Norman ah I didn't see an unmute button
can you hear me can hear you okay
awesome so U this is one of those bills
where it's a pleasure to be before you
with everyone in agreement um before um
the Senate finished on this bill it was
negotiated through and the Troublesome
parts that at least for us were trou
some were taken care of uh we had
meetings with LA Barry we had meetings
with the director of The Human Rights
Commission and both landlord and tenant
communities are in agreement with this
bill as it stands as it came from the
Senate the part one uh as you heard
would change it so that the tenants
would have until the court hearing to
pay what they owe but what they would
have to do at that point is is to pay
all lawful charges owed to that point so
simple language there is that it would
make landlords whole so if the tenant
makes the landlord hold by the time of
the hearing it's totally reasonable that
they would stay in their um
location uh the provisions that some of
you may know could be Loosely termed
fourth strike you're out that remains so
if a tenant was constantly behind and
used this clause three times in a
12-month period on the fourth time then
it would become the option for the
landlord to say not you know even if
you're paying up we still would rather
not continue um it's true that this does
not add any time to the total eviction
cost whether it was existing law or with
this change the
timetable the the full timetable is the
same so part two is really simple it
just says that the welfare departments
giving rental assistance cannot hold
back giving that assistance if the
tenant doesn't have an eviction
notice um we think that's a good thing
uh in present law occasionally you have
a welfare department that says we're not
going to entertain giving assistance to
a tenant unless they come to us with an
eviction
notice which just seems silly like
they're going to get assistance so they
don't get
evicted um and in practice we've had
many times where uh tenant is trying to
get assistance and then we we have to
give them an eviction notice so they can
go to the town to uh to get that
assistance it just seems like an un
unnecessary um delay and needless
eviction
notices part three is all about about
bringing New Hampshire discrimination
law language to be the same as Federal
language we did have a big meeting uh
with the Director of Human Rights and
our real estate core team specialist
that specializes in discrimination law
poured through it fairly well with a
fine tooth comb the things that
were changing New Hampshire law were
removed so all that's left here is
bringing New Hampshire law into
compliance with federal law when I say
changing New Hampshire law I guess I
should say changing the entire picture
between Federal and and state with the
bill as it is now the total picture of
the Discrimination law is not changing
but New Hampshire's language is now
mirroing Federal language that just
makes it every easier for everybody
involved in the process to have one set
of uh rules guidelines language to to
deal with I'd be very very happy to to
take any
questions are there any questions for Mr
Norman seeing none thank you for your
testimony very
much there
is Anie
Malachi morning and thank you um can you
hear me everyone we can hear you fine
excellent thank you very much uh
chairman Gordon and members of the
Judiciary Committee excuse me uh my name
is Annie Malachi I am the executive
director of the commission for human
rights uh the commission certainly is in
support of sb26 and would ask that the
committee would support this bill as
amended uh this piece of legislation as
others have spoken uh specifically part
three uh is needed to allow the
commission to begin the Contracting
process with HUD upon approval this
workshare agreement uh would reimburse
the commission for work that it work
work that it does already and elements
completed this work is something that
the commission currently does um and
there are some language changes which
Nick Norman specified um that are
addressed in this bill to allow the
state of New Hampshire to be what is
called substantially equivalent with the
federal fair housing act um and as Mr
Norman pointed out and Mr Barry um there
were several meetings had with various
stakeholders to explain and improve upon
the original Bill and through the
addition of an amendment addressed the
concerns that the stakeholders had um I
think that encapsulates basically
everything thank you for your time and
your consideration and I'm happy to take
any questions that you might
have thank you are there any questions
for Miss
Mali I'm sorry I didn't do a very good
job with your name at the beginning that
is
okay seeing no questions thank you thank
you for your testimony today thank you
Brandon
L yeah
see oh sorry about that hello everybody
uh my name is Brandon lame uh I am
representing rights and democracy I am
the housing Justice organizer for them
uh I'm here speaking in favor of Senate
Bill 126 um I really don't want to
reiterate what's already been said um
and I think I just want to emphasize uh
I don't really think that this bill is
controversial uh to anybody uh because
it benefits both tenants and landlords
alike uh making it easier for folks to
access assistance uh before receiving an
eviction notice is a great step to
ensure that residents can stay in their
homes and that landlords can get the
income at the same time um simply put I
just think that this is a winwin um and
as it's been stated part three just make
sure that our codes are in line with
other states and the federal government
um ensuring that we can have access to
vital federal funds uh so and as we all
know uh tackling the housing Cris in New
Hampshire will require some of these
federal funds um so I think I'm just
going to wrap that up I don't want to
Again State what's already been stated
so I thank you very much for your
time thank thank you for your testimony
your brief testimony there any
questions Mr L seeing none thank you
thank you uh the next person is Martha
Stone
good morning can you hear me hear you
fine great thank you chairman Gordon and
the committee I appreciate the
opportunity to speak to you I'll try to
be brief this morning and not repeat um
some of the comments made by other folks
um I'm speaking to you this morning um
wearing two hats I am both the executive
director of Crossroads house one of our
state's homeless shelters for
individuals and families I am also
speaking to you as a member of housing
action New Hampshire um I speak as many
others have already in favor of SB 1226
um I certainly support the opportunity
for any tenant to make payments to be
able to um catch up and as others have
said um make a landlord whole before um
they are are Lo actually in a position
where they're losing their housing unit
from my perspective as the Director of
an emergency shelter once someone is
evicted and and becomes homeless if they
don't have anywhere to go it's
extraordinarily difficult to get back
into a new apartment both because they
may have an eviction on their record but
also just because as I'm sure you're
well aware the housing rental housing
stock is is very very low in our region
it's a we have a 1% vacancy rate and the
prices are Sky High so everything we can
do to support tenants to be able to
catch up on their rent um is is
definitely a great strategy um because
as we see once people have um been
forced to move out of their Apartments
the lengths of stay that we're finding
in shelters in our state is rising as
are the number of people experiencing
homelessness um excuse me in addition um
we are we're getting very close to the
end of the eviction moratorium um that
ends on June 30th and so we're already
starting to see um you know we
anticipate there could be a surge in
those who are um are potentially going
to be evicted and the this new um policy
would allow more people the opportunity
to take advantage of the federal
resources that you've heard about as
well that are available um to be able to
catch up on on their rent so as we start
to see an increase already in the
landlord tenant eviction cases um this
certainly be a helpful
policy and um I think the rest people
have already said I just wanted to also
add that um housing action New Hampshire
also supports part two so that welfare
support is able to flow without
requiring notices of eviction so um
that's it again wearing both my hats
from an emergency shelter provider and
as a member of housing action New
Hampshire and I thank you for um
allowing me this
time repres pres MC Beth did you have a
question yes thank you um Mr chair and
thank you m stone for taking my question
you mentioned that um the evictions are
once someone's homeless the the length
of stay is longer it impacts the length
of stay what's negative about the length
of stay what what what are the Fallout
from that yes so um I've been tracking
our length of stay at our shelter and
it's significantly increased by um more
than 20% over the past um five or six
years we're up to 103 days is the
average so we have some people that are
um you know some people who stay in a
shelter may come in just literally for a
couple of days they're in they're out
they're not really seeking our full
array of Supportive Services but those
who come and engage and get case
management and are actually looking to
get back on their feet and back in an
apartment it can take months and months
and months with the waiting lists for
public housing being lengthy But to
answer your question the negative impact
of an increased length of stay is
that for every person that has to stay
in an emergency shelter they're taking
up a bed that is not available for the
next person who needs it and so
especially given our covid restrictions
to um last night we had 66 people
sleeping at our shelter um we've been
averaging more like 70 to 80 during
covid but a year ago March when the
pandemic hit we had 100 20 people in our
shelter and we were able to kind of pack
people in if you will which is not the
most Humane thing to do but it's better
than sleeping outside um but most well
all emergency shelters in the state are
still limited in our ability to utilize
all of our space due to covid
restrictions so every night that a bed
is occupied by someone because they
can't get into housing um it's not
available to someone else and our
ability to flex to get more people in is
still limited so I hope that answers
your question if not I'm happy for a
followup no thank you very much thank
you Mr
chair representative D
Lorenzo thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Miss stone for taking my question I
just wanted to um ask you about your
shelter population does your shelter um
serve families and individuals thank you
yes it does we have separate dorm rooms
for single men single women and we have
separate spaces for families as
well and we are still housing um some of
our families um and individuals at our
shelter and we continue to keep a few
people um using local motel rooms which
was a strategy we employed during Co to
increase our capacity to meet the need
but yes we do to shelter both families
and individuals and we have infants
through teenagers at any given time um I
believe we have 18 children right now
thank you and thank you for your work
you're
welcome any other questions
forone seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank
you next we call upon Sarah
Holland
good morning can you hear me we can
excellent my name is Sarah Holland I am
the broker and owner of a real estate
firm located in Plymouth I'm also the
vice chair of the New Hampshire
Association of realtor public policy
committee I'm here today to voice nh's
support for section three of Senate Bill
126 the Realtors worked with the Human
Rights Commission to craft an amendment
to the Senate Bill 126 prior to the hear
in in the Senate those changes added
definitions and clarified discriminatory
acts which aligned with existing federal
laws all of our questions and concerns
were dealt with in that Amendment so we
fully support the passage of that
section in the past our industry has
played a regrettable role in
perpetuating discrimination in the home
buying process while much of the of
while much work has been accomplished
over the past decades such as ending red
lining and discriminatory restrictive C
we still have the long way to go RSA
354a is an important part of the state's
ongoing effort to eliminate
discrimination in real estate we want to
especially thank director Malachi of the
Human Rights Commission for her
willingness to work with our association
in drafting the Senate Amendment what
you see much of what you see in
s226 is already contained in the federal
fair housing laws as others have said
thank you for your
time thank you any questions from Miss
Holland see n thank you for testifying
today thank
you uh Lindy
Lincoln good morning um my name is
Lindsay Lincoln I am an attorney and
co-director of the fairh housing project
at New Hampshire legal assistance um
since everything I was going to say has
been covered um I will uh pass my time
but appreciate the opportunity thank
you thank you very much for your brief
testimony and the next person would be
Notch
Grace thank you Mr chair H Grace from
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
I I don't believe commentary on our part
is necessary at this time thank
you thank you very
much that concludes the people who
pre-reg registered to testify today are
there is there anyone else who is in
attendance who wishes to testify
today if you if there is please raise
your hand so we can
identify it's Asma
elone yes hello can you hear me we can
yeah I may have been the person to
register in opposition to this bill and
if so I'm just um changing uh to support
so that you'll have all people I I
didn't realize the nature of the bill um
was that my name that registered in
opposition uh you are not the person who
registered okay okay I appla all right
so just here to say I definitely support
this I volunteer with mutual Aid in the
Upper Valley and I see a need for this
bill it's good for tenants it's good for
landlords it's just a good bill in
general and I'm speaking as a resident
of New Hampshire and not for rights and
democracy thank
you thank
you uh seeing no other hands raised at
this point in time we'll close the
hearing on Senate Bill
126 and at this point in
time we
will we schedule for to reconvene at
1:00 today for executive session on two
bills on three bills excuse me and so
we'll recess until 1 o' thank you
everybody thank you see you
soon thank
you all this
time
yep
good afternoon
all good good afternoon
Paul hello
all all have your
cop so it says that one pile is complete
set so like I'm supposed to grab all of
these and then all of
these h no no I think it's
just no maybe it is
yeah um is this the same as the Hat yeah
there's like okay so that pile is for
him yeah am here yeah sounds complicated
it is
I
know each pil well there's not enough
here mine too there's not enough can you
want to sit by me so we
can
all ready press
in
okay
[Applause]
okay uh
oh
[Music]
call this meeting of the house Judiciary
Committee back
order sched this afternoon for an
executive
session three bills Senate Bill 41
Senate Bill 143 and Senate Bill 13
4 we
will do our best to complete our
executive session on each of those bills
today in fact we did have to carry over
the schedule for further executive
session next
week
and I note that we've been
joined by uh representative mner who
here
uh filling in today substituting for
represent silver that was newly noted in
advance
by most speakers office
majority
and unless
there's other formalities to deal with
we'll move on to addressing Senate 41
representative Mr chair um if I can just
apologize for to the Comm for missing
the public hearings this morning um I
had something else going on already but
thank you thank you for having me glad
to hear this
afternoon so uh the
um the first bill is sen Bill 41
relative to police disciplinary
hearings I note that we uh we only heard
from one speaker on the bill and that
was from the attorney this the primary
sponsor didn't
appear I was gonna make a motion when we
ready oh thank you Mr chair um um I'd
like to make a motion uh to uh retain uh
sp41 and speak to that
motion uh yeah thank you Mr chair so um
when the ACLU came in and they testified
on this bill they supported the bill um
and there's a lot that that's good about
it for transparency point of view
however they did recommend retention
because there was a parallel Bill HB
471 uh that was going through and they
felt that the language was cleaner there
one of the questions that we had was um
when you make a petition um who was it
made to that wasn't specified in sb41
and it is an hb4 471 so um I just would
ask that we retain the bill until we
understand the ultimate fate of HB
471 I should asked is there a second
motion
toet seconded
by and is there any other discussion yes
representative
bur uh thank you Mr
chair um in I'm kind of puzzled since
there was no objection to the bill uh
why we need to retain it or what would
really be gained by uh spending
summertime working on it the the
question that uh uh my good friend just
raised as to who should be petitioned as
referred to in line six of the bill it
was see fairly obvious at least to me
that if we're if there's a disciplinary
hearing and one of the parties has a
requests it would go to uh the person or
persons conducting the hearing uh and
they would ask um that uh a decision be
made on on closure so I I I think the
the bill is pretty clear as to um what
is required and I think there's at least
from my perspective no problem if we
just pass this
bill than chair so all
[Music]
respect sent a good bill to theate we
don't need we are hling over two
separate bills de the same thing so
let's just hle all we one we can retain
this if something could happen
471 somehow doesn't go all the way
through and we'll still have
it to work on
and any correction we need
to shots retain only get
one any other
discussion I I do recall uh I had asked
some questions about the
bill and the
the and I I remember attorney
banet indicated that the other Bill
House Bill 471 was clearer and one was I
know one of the questions was it
mentions confidential information but it
doesn't Define confidential information
in this
bill and it uses the term compelling
interest but it doesn't explain what
creates what might create a compelling
interest and it also doesn't specify in
here who actually makes the decisions to
whether there's a compelling interest so
I think that was and and he indicated
that he thought House Bill 471 was
clearer and that we should prend we
should retain the
bill representative bir uh in view of
the of the comments
uh made by my colleagues here uh I will
withdraw my objection uh or point of
view as to retaining it's uh it's fine
by me to retain
it any other questions or
comments seeing none the motion is to
retain Senate Bill 41 and representative
wer do you want want to take the rooll
I'm retaining Hospital 471
representative M yes representative
siia trying to get my video there we go
yeses alexer yes
representative yes representative murder
yes representative greed yes
representative Kelly
yes
representative representative Melvin
yes representative
smithi
muted
welome back
represent uh
yes representative Oregon
yes representative dorenzo
yes
represent
yep she's we're we're having trouble
hearing I'm I'm not sure who was called
representative chase is on the hook
right now but representative
Kenny
yes
representa
yes representative MC
yes representative Paige yes
representative
yes okay representative to
oh
yes representative
Tosh okay representative Smith
yes
okay Mak it
20 20 to
zero yes can
I
is representative chase you
here not here she's not
here it makes it
zero
yes
okay told me
that representing
McBeth thank you I just the the the um
audio is very garbled it's very
difficult to hear it sound I think it's
every one of you that was just talking
it was couldn't understand thank you
w as I'm speaking right now is it is it
clear that was much better thank
you move on to Senate Bill
143 which is an Omnibus
Bill dealing with certain agency
requests and the plan I think the plan
is to go through part by part because I
know there are amendments relative to
certain parts in the bill
the first part being appointment of
council for a minor and a juvenile
delinquency
proceeding I I know that there are there
have been a couple different amendments
offered and representative
bir uh thank you Mr share I I guess my
first question is a bit
procedural um I do have an amendment to
present and would offer which is uh uh
H I don't know if there is going to be
um an amendment
uh which has a
senate uh heading on it from Senator
Carson in some
respects it's better to compare and
contrast the two from my
perspective uh rather than have two
separate consecutive arguments the
number on her bill or or amendment is
0969 s and I'm not sure procedurally
whether that can even be
introduced can't take
us okay my clerk tells me that we can't
take a senate Amendment all right in
that case I will speak to um 1267 but
first I would move its
admission okay
just so I thought we could uh offer a as
long as somebody from the committee
offer the
amendment that was uh I think that was
our understanding that if somebody when
the committee offered the amendment then
it was uh in its text that it would be
satisfactory do do you yeah so it would
be my opinion that's all it is uh that
we are if we agree to the am language of
the amendment we can agree to the
amendment 10 number change but yes we
can't officially cannot put an S
Amendment Senate
Amendment if we agree that's what we
want to
do is uh I guess I'm looking to the
committee what I can do is uh I can have
this sent over I'll have the researcher
send it over and convert it into a house
of Amendment and then we'll come back to
part one if you'd like to do
that does that make
sense I think it does and I I
apologize if if I messed up
so so do we want to skip part one we'll
come back to part
one would that be okay with everyone yes
yes that's fine we
all okay part two relative to recovery
of unauthorized payments by the
state is there an amendment by
anyone
yes um Mr chair wait a
minute
oh
lordy I'm sorry um yes um Mr chair I
would like to um move Amendment 12
52h start
right and
that life is coming to an end wait one
[Music]
second
I apologize to the
committee
um
naturally this happens just at the
crucial moment um that I'm somehow on
two
different
appliances um has there been a second to
this
amendment is there a second to the
amendment I'll second it okay I I think
I saw representative MCB in
first thank you very much
[Music]
um Mr
chair I strongly ask that you um support
this amendment which removes section two
part two excuse me from this
bill the department has a special
investigations
unit the Union has 11 employees
full-time one part-time and a cost of
about 990 million a
year currently state law allows recovery
only from future
grants this section will require a
recipient of Public Assistance to pay
the department back for what the
department determines are unauthorized
payments made to that person in the past
the term
unauthorized is an interesting term in
fact the department authorized the
payments and that's why the payments
were
made subsequent
investigation raised questions about the
payments um in some cases it might be
that the recipient filled out a form
incorrectly or did not know that they
had to reapply every year
in some cases the department made a
mistake in calculating the payment the
department made the mistake in
calculating the payment this is the
Department's reasoning of why they want
to be able to seek money
retroactively I was told that if a
person's been able to do everything that
expected of him or her and is able to
withdraw from receiving any public
assistance um because they are now
earning money um that is the time to ask
them to
repay um a mistaken payment the mistake
might have been made by the recipient
and it might have been made by the
department so at the very time that the
recipient has been able to do exactly
what we want them to do has been able to
get a job and barely pull themselves out
and above line of of uh being able to
support themselves at that very moment
that's when the department would swoop
in and um and uh and ask for repayment
and the reason in is because that's the
time when they might have the money of
course by doing this it's very possible
that the recipient will then fall below
the line again and have to start the
process all over of trying trying to get
back on his or her
feet might make sense to you it doesn't
make sense to me they have a program
they refer to as Fred
frontend detection I love those cute
names for
programs about half the money they take
credit for falls into this category
which they refer to as cost avoidance in
other words this is money that they have
not spent cost avoidance
but where they have caught errors before
payment was made I asked how much
related to errors in calculations made
by the
department rather than misstatements
made by the potential recipient they
could not answer that question I asked
how much money was C categorized as
general fund dollars rather than total
dollars they could not answer that
question other than cost avoidance as
discussed above the amount they collect
is about the same perhaps a little less
as they spend on salaries and
benefits I do not have the figure on how
much they spend in other categories in
the budget I do not believe that anyone
who deliberately misrepresents their
financial circumstances should be
protected legitimate procedures should
be followed to collect money for which
the recipient was not eligible but if
the department is responsible for the
error then I do not think the recipient
should be punished I want to remove
section two that adds the ability to go
after someone no longer receiving aid
and I hope you will support
me I believe that government plays an
important role in a Democratic Society
but I do not believe that government
should have unlimited power and I hope
you agree with me on that if in the
fullness of
time the department is able to provide
better explanation of this program and
make sure that the guilty are in fact
held guilty and the innocent are
protected then I would be the first one
to support the effort but today I really
hope you will agree with me that this
section is not ready for prime time and
I would ask you to support the amendment
which
removes uh part two from the Bill thank
you Mr chair for indulging
me any
discussion yes representative Chase hi
yes thank you very much and I'm sorry
it's not discussion but I wanted to let
representative wer know that I am on and
able to vote thank
you yes representative mlan yeah um I'm
uh I'm going to support repres
representative Smith's Amendment uh it's
a it's a tough call for me because I'm
not a fan of fraud uh especially in
programs like this
where
oh oh are we recording again are so and
so and I don't want people to perceive
that that I I favor fraud but I think
that you know where there's an
opportunity for the Departments to be in
error and especially in the the middle
of a pandemic um where I know uh I've
had calls from multiple constituents
including a disabled veteran where
they've been caught up in a whole bunch
of administrative errors and I've had to
speak to department heads and
Commissioners I I really think um that
this is is not the time uh to be doing
it in the case of true fraud as
representative Smith said there are
other tools available and so we need to
be pursuing fraud we have to hold people
accountable but we have to temper that
accountability with a little bit of
mercy and so I'm going to be supporting
her
Amendment any other
discussion yes representative Langley
thank you Mr chair I too would support
uh representative Smith's Amendment and
um Wanted to express my concern with the
Department's um uh efforts to recoup
money uh from people as they begin to
stabilize their lives and become
productive citizens um as representative
mlan just stated I I also do not support
fraud but when you look at the numbers
that were provided by the department the
number uh the department recouped less
than what it cost them to uh investigate
um the people that were alleged to have
committed the fraud so I think it the
numbers spoke for themselves thank
you any other
discussion
seeing
none seeing no further
discussion we have a an amendment
proposed which is 2021 1252
H you can call Mr CL on Amendment
1252 Bill 143
removing plan
yes representative
snia representative Sylvia
no CL votes yes representative Alexander
yes representative nter yes
representative Mard yes representative
green yes representative Kelly yes
representative
to not here I
forgot representative Melvin
yes representative Smith yes
representative ber
yes representative Oregon
yes representative lenzo
yes representative
Chase
no you're there yeah sorry you can't
hear me yes yes
yes yes yes
yes representative Kenny
yes representative Langley yes
representative mcth yes representative
Paige yes representative
Simpson
yes Mr chairman yes
meting 19 to one motion
car
pass okay the amendment has passed is
and I guess we are open to at this point
in time I guess since it removes that
section there's no need for further
amendments move on to part
three the vote on that
representative 19 to one 191 okay part
three relative to Alternative dispute
resolution any proposed amendments to
that
[Music]
so uh Mr chairman
uh
does somebody want to
Mr could I ask a question of the chair
yes you may um Mr chair um if there is
no amendment to any particular section
um I would think that we need to vote on
each section we only need to vote on the
Amendments and then at the end vote on
the entire bill so we
um uh the first section we're waiting
now to convert a bill from Senate to
house the second we've just eliminated
the third if they no amendments um we
would just go on to the fourth section
do you see it differently no I think
you're right as usual I think we're just
waiting to see if representative wer had
an amendment
am
although totally
unnecessary well if you can get an
amendment before we're finished
executing here today then that would be
fine but otherwise we'll be moving
on part four allowing judicial referees
to issue orders and non-contested
probate
me is there any anyone who want wishes
to offer an amendment to
that see none part five permitting a
Supreme Court Justice to sit as a
circuit court
judge no one offering an
amendment
part
six relative to payment of cost for
services other than counil for Indigent
par is there an amendment to
that seeing
none part seven requiring a penalty
assessment on
violations chairman I do have an
amendment for that
one and I would like to
offer Amendment
two2 and and Mr chair I would second
that
Amendment and what was that Amendment
again so relative to penalty assessments
on violations yeah what was the
amendment number oh I'm sorry
H and so that was moov by representative
Sylvia and seconded by representative
Smith
correct and just to speak very briefly
on this
um there is a bit of confusion I guess
uh apparently assessments are already uh
applied to violations U but the law does
not NE necessarily provide for it I'm
not sure how that happens but I don't
want to be instituting a section into
the statute to correct uh something
that's perhaps not done right I'm not
sure exactly how that
works any other discussion on the
amendment seeing none I think Mr clerk
you could call the
role on Amendment 272 to Senate
143 part
s representative main yes representative
syvia
yes yes representative Alexander
no representative n yes representative
mner yes representative greed
yes representative Kelly
yes representative Melvin
yes representative
Smith
yes representative Burke
yes representative organ
yes representative Renzo
yes representative Chase
yes representative Kenny
yes representative
Langley representative
Lany you're muted yes I'm
sorry representative McBeth
yes representative Paige
yes representative Simpson
yes
yes 19
to1 moving on
to part eight part
nine has part eight part
eight cyber
security
uh representative Sylvia has an
amendment he representative
Sylvia uh so I have an amendment uh one
1274 that I would like to move and this
would remove the the
section is that
seconded I'll second it seconded by
representative
mlan and you want to address your motion
syvia yes uh thank you Mr chairman um in
in looking at this uh we have a statute
that there are two parts to it that
might be a problem and I believe uh
representative Smith was going to
address part of it being a 28a issue of
a mandate for U
municipalities but the more troubling
aspect I guess is that this is a bill
with no actual mandate uh while it says
it needs to be done and it suggests
things should be done there is certainly
no uh penalty for a violation of it so
essentially this turns into putting a
suggestion into statute and I think um
our statutes are full of things that
actually um tend to be ignored already
so uh I don't think this is necessary
and therefore I would just assum have it
not in the
bill any other discussion
cler I think you call the RO on
Amendment
moving representa M yes represent
syia
yes yes representative n yes
representative mner yes
representative green yes representative
Kelly
yes representative noin
yes representative
Smith
no is that no no
no no
okay representative B
no represent oron
no representative de Renzo
no representative Chase
no representative Kenny
no
Lang
no representa MC no
representative p
no representative
Simpsons
no Mr chairman
yes um Mr chair um I wasn't called on
during that
vote did you call Representative
Alexander represent Alexander I
you I don't remember voting so um if I
if I forgot about me voting I vote Yes
again okay thank
you so the motion uh fails it's 10 to
10 is there another
motion is there another
amendment
[Applause]
now ordinarily i' think i' know what to
do if this was a separate bill but I'm
not exactly sure what to do if it's a
part so I guess it just stays in the way
it is if
um and part nine relative to emergency
medical and Trauma Services
data
Mr chair yes um I did have an amendment
um on part nine but it also addresses
part 10
so I so I'll I'll offer it uh uh
Amendment 1223
H um and so what amendment 1223 does
basically is it takes both part nine and
part 10 out of the uh out of the bill
part 10 nobody really came at all to
testify on part 10 um so I'm not sure
that I have a full understanding of what
it's trying to do um part nine was uh
the the sharing of uh Medical Data you
know for data Gathering and research and
while that may be well-intentioned and
it may be to the good um
there's authorization within that part
of the bill that would allow for the
sharing of non-anonymized data as well
as aggregate data and I I it does have a
privacy Council set up but how that
would operate and what rules it would
operate under I don't really think we
really had the opportunity to V any of
that and so while there may be Merit to
it I don't think you know buried an an
omous bill is where this should be it
should have its own uh airing in the
light of day so um Amendment one 223
basically removes both those parts from
the
bill second if you need it second uh so
it's moved by representative mlan
seconded by represented
Sylvia basically removing Parts nine and
parts 10 from Senate Bill
143 is there any other discussion I'd
like to offer uh something if I may you
sure can uh so I I'm particularly
troubled by this uh section nine and the
uh the data that's going to be
collected um find it very
troubling data is becoming
uh uh big business and uh the people's
privacy is is affected by this so I
would say our our
Constitution and our right to privacy is
uh important and this bill is less
important and therefore we should remove
it any
other discussion
seeing none I guess Mr clerk you could
call the
rooll okay so on
Amendment 1223 38 REM moving Parts n and
10 from SD
143 representative the CL yes
representative Sylvia yes
cours representative Alexander
yes representative n yes representative
M yes representative green
yes representative Kelly
yes representative Melvin yes
representative
Smith uh
no representative B
no representative
Oregon
uh
no repres Lorenzo
no representative Chase
no representative Kenny no
representative Langley
noes MC
no p
no
Simpson
no Mr chairman
yes
10 motion having
failed guess we move on to part
Smith
uh
no I'm not bringing that forward thank
you
part 11 relative to insurance company
licenses no
Amendment and part 12 regard to the
National
Guard
Mr chairman I have a uh an amendment for
Section 13 because these omous goals are
not uh big
enough
okay what would be your
amendment I find the right screen I have
a an amendment
uh
1280 and I would move that and I'll tell
you all about
it is there a
second second seconded by representative
wer you want to address your Amendment
yes so um this uh brings into the bill
uh the substance of
hb31 as amended which is a bill on civil
ass asset forfeiture uh that the
committee passed and put on the consent
calendar and the Senate chose to kill it
um so I would like uh the committee to
uh consider uh sending this back to the
Senate and uh letting them reconsider
this piece of legislation that's very
important for protecting due process
rights of people who have uh property
seized representative syia can you give
me the number
again believe it was
representative
bur yeah it's just a a quick uh moment
of support uh for this uh uh Amendment
and for the concept of this committee
protecting the due process rights of
citizens Visa the government so I will
be supporting this
and any other
discussion none call the
roll we're catching up on the
paper Amendment
consider adding
to the
bill
yes representa syia
yes yes representative Alexander
no representative n yes representative
merer yes representative green
yes representative Kelly
yes representative Melvin yes
representative Smith
yes representative B
yes representative Oregon
no representative Renzo
yes representative Chase
yes representative
Kenny
yes representative Langley
yes representa MC yes
representative Paige
yes representative
Simpson
yes Mr
yes adopted Amendment
1280 and with a new section Al it won't
be 13 because we've deleted some other
sections not L sure what
section excuse me could you repeat that
vote total again please 18
to2 thank
you Mr chair I was wondering if it might
be possible for us to recess just for a
little bit I know that we have a couple
amendments that we sent out to be
converted I know that you had one on 143
and based on that ruling I realized I
had to have another uh Amendment from
Senator Carson's relative to 134
converted over so I just like to have
the opportunity to get those converted
and then we could maybe
resume so uh what we'll do is um I think
we if we could
recess uh
till give us let's say if we recess to
quarter past
two
okay uh could I suggest an alternative I
I don't know if you're interested in
that is um that we
um move
on we we do not close the executive
session on on this um but we move on to
the executive session on the next bill
um or does that make things
confusing I think it it makes it
confusing for me okay oh no no I don't
want to do that I would never do that
Mr chair Mr chair might I
inquire we only have one section
obviously left in
143 and I know we were waiting for a uh
um a repaired Amendment uh has have you
received that I mean the only change is
from an S to an H have you received that
yet
no and also representative Burch um
based on that rule there was an
amendment from Senator Carson on 134
dealing with part one that I had to have
converted as well so before we go 134
I'd like that right I was just trying to
figure out if we could just finish 143
at this point um also that's a long
delay and I know that the house Dems are
having a caucus which we will
undoubtedly those of us here miss a good
chunk of but I'd like to catch a little
bit of it and so maybe if the would
shorten that uh period of time a little
bit the court excuse me the
chair old
habits the
uh I need I need do need a little bit of
time
um I
Al to
uh to get those amendments here if if
you wouldn't object to
that but we get I don't know what
this
status he's coming
down
supposedly they're being delivered as we
speak so is there a few moments for a
right yes if if and and right now
it's s minutes to so if if we could just
go till five P that would be helpful
just take a break for five pass
okay f with
me
[Music]
rft yesterday morning 10es
o'
[Music]
number
is
in
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
there
temp
h
we're not
yes I have nothing to
hide
no my apologies I thought we could offer
a senate Amendment but obviously you're
ruling on
143 as soon as you did that I said oh
well that's going to have implications
on 134 as well so that'll have to be
tightened
up
okay
just letting you know Mark that the
whole world can hear you yes but I I
have nothing to hide representative ver
especially from you well I know that
just being
cautious very good to know I Know What
You Did Last
Summer well don't tell my
wife
Mark I can't believe that you would ever
do anything that you would not share
with your
wife be right
99.9% of the time represent
Smith that's good
enough as your attorney representative I
advise you to just stop right
there
mine still worked
on
well let's see hopefully we have it
all
what's
that
uh that not not mine I think that that
was sent down as
well I I gave him a copy of that
too
that's what I
heard
are
you uh I yes if I send you something for
some reason it's not identifying my
house Judiciary Committee okay s send it
over mark
mle
okay here we go if you could send that
out to the
commit
okay
okay back
online we don't have the we did we get
things back no got the things back so
what we'll do is we'll move on to
134 and we'll come back and we'll finish
as soon as we get those other things
back
we'll on
134 the first section is prohibiting
certain uses of laser pointing devices
is that your Amendment yes we won't go
on to part two I'll address that part
two revised uniform law on notori acts
and uniform real property Electronic
Reporting
Act and Mr chair are you back in session
yes we are I I'm sorry I didn't hear you
say that sorry
okay I just and said we're ready to go
so we are call it house Judiciary Comm
back
order we'll deal with with Senate Bill
134 we do still have some amendments
that are coming on 143 and we'll go back
and do those and finish that as soon as
we're
a about 134 we have section
one we are waiting an amendment on
section one as well and the issue there
was it was another amendment that had
been prepared by Senator Carson and we
just having a house number put on or a
house
designation part two is the uniform law
notarial acts and the uniform real
property electronic recording
act so Mr chairman I have Amendment
you know the number yeah
1248 sent it to the entire
committee days
ago and they're moving that amend I
that I
either I have
[Music]
my
yes my
only I'll give it right
so the amendment went through 4 I I'm
expecting that all the Judiciary
Committee members have
it because sent by email about six days
ago uh and what it does is it replaces
the definition of electronic signature
in two parts to the
built both in part two section three and
in part two section
10 and in each
place it changes the definition from the
quite broad vague definition that's in
it to the definition that's used by the
FDIC which was suggested to us by the
registry
deeds and that was there only objection
to this bill which was actually I know
the only
objection that we really got the
registry
ofs so that's what the amendment does
just changes the definition of
electronic
signature first of all was there a
second to representative W's
motion I'll second second it by
represent
ready
discuss yes representative D
Loreno thank you Mr chair and thank you
U representative welper for taking my
question I'm trying to figure out um how
the electronic signature becomes
encrypted in this
instance um and the answer
is over my
head the answer I have is the what the
words you see in front of you apparently
this is a private key trans uh uh
encryption in which in which place only
one person has that private key and has
to give it anybody else that wants to
open I don't exactly understand
this what I do know about it is that as
was explained to us by uh rean from the
Mart County
registry that the definition of
electronic signature was a big problem
during mortgage crisis and caused a lot
of the problems that they had and that a
result of that the
FDIC has changed its definition to
this I know two things about that one
this does work because it is in
use and two it it fixes the only problem
that was identified with this language
in all the testimony that we
got okay thank
you yes
I apologize I just want to I'm gotten a
little bit confused so what is the
number of the amendment that we are
considering right
now 124
Z if you just so you'll
know and that's not I'm I'm sorry May is
that one of the new ones or that's an
old one that's is that all new because
none have been introduced but uh I sent
this by email to the Judiciary Committee
on April
30th thank you so you should have it in
your
email but it's the Senate version I
have no this is the house oh okay all
right so it's not I'm okay I just was
clarifying it wasn't one of the new ones
that was just drafted thank you we're on
a different
now
[Music]
no no not
new yes uh representative
bur uh thank you uh and thank you
representative for taking my question I
gather this is a uh a public key private
key encryption system which I'm
wondering whether is kind of an overload
for you know what a notary needs to go
through and I'm wondering how this would
impact uh notarization for people who
don't have uh um either the electronic
knowledge to do this uh or an ability to
keep this electronic data uh secret yet
available over considerable periods of
time
so it's my expectation that everybody
that uses this would just buy software
that
doesn't representative
Simpson you're
muted representative Simpson sorry I was
looking sorry I was looking at the
amendment um and didn't realize I was
muted
um sorry forgive me for not figuring
this out myself but I have a question
about the um when I'm reading the
amendment does it just replace a
definition or does it replace the entire
section 10 no no just a definition okay
great
thanks and representative
MC um so I do have concerns um that but
I I'm sorry I need to look at the
current law that that's not what
electronic signature means to me I've
been electronic filing some things with
the judicial branch but I'm I I just
need to clarify so I won't I let me
thank
you I mean do you chair have a is that
what electronic s signature means to you
is that or have you been using I I don't
mean to put you on the spot I'm just
curious uh in the the uses that I'm
currently involved with they aren't as
technical as that and in terms of
encryption
so that's it's new to
me thank you I think that's how I'm
feeling too thank
you represent Horgan um yes thank you
very much um I mean my concern is well
first of all I think this wasn't the
registers of deed only objection to the
wording of the bill so I think
we um they you there were I mean there
were I'm also like not exactly
encryption key is an encryption keys I'm
not exactly sure how that's the same
thing as an electronic signature so I
feel like even though I'm not a lawyer
this is something I feel like
I seems to me I either either this is
like not a good substitute for the
language on electronic signature or
maybe there's a hole of my knowledge so
maybe want maybe R wber can clarify a
little bit more about how an encryption
key is the same thing as an electronic
signature because iide of the signature
just a remark that tells you verify
tells you who the person was who who
signed it so I I just don't I just don't
get it I'm sorry to say I just
don't but maybe you can enlighten
me I've had correspondence with the
registers of deeds and in particularly
the president of the register of deeds
associate
a her her concern wasn't with the
electronic signature as much as it
was uh the ability to have signatures on
documents such as plats and maps and
surveys that uh and that was raised that
day and subsequently raised and they
actually wrote a letter to us which I
think we all reive saying that they
objected to Part 10 of the bill but I've
since heard from them and and I I have
an amendment as well which corrects that
part which they're in agreement with and
indicated that if that Amendment passed
they would be
satisfied if I could just ask uh
representative
wer the the the
FDIC uh the amendment that you have was
that something that was given to you by
the registers is something that they
wanted
yes and she's particularly concerned
about it in terms
of
so any other represent MC
Beth well I hadn't lowered my hand but I
I just was doing a little bit of
research um I don't this definition I
don't know where the language come came
from but I it's it's not one that I see
that's used typically in some of the
like electronic systems that I've been
using frequently but I I appreciate the
concern
um thank you that's
it any other discussion on the amendment
this is amendment
I guess the question is do you feel
comfortable I I don't understand it is
what it comes down to and I guess the
question is do I feel comfortable voting
for it if I don't understand
it okay uh representative D
Lorenzo you're
muted
for the group I'd like to offer sort of
a simple explanation of encryption um so
encryption would be
the partty a agrees to exchange a
document with partty two
and both have sort of like a
passcode to get into the document so
that if I if I sign let's say a form um
they'll be like it will be scrambled by
the the system and each party has a key
that will unscramble the um the
information that's it it's like having a
password to someone's signature that's
only shared by two P two people the
party that's the simplest I could I
could make
it so are you supportive of the
amendment
yes any other
discussion
so I yeah so I I I appreciate my
distinguished colleague from uh new
markets explanation I guess I I and I
appreciate that but what I don't
understand what I'm concerned about is
having each party having the software to
do the encryption and communicate with
each other and it seems like what we're
you know we're talking about a broader
Network where everyone's not going to
have that so I won't be able ble to
support the amendment
um thank
you is if I could just ask question
representative wer does that your
Amendment apply to the whole bill or
simply to the recordable documents
part and the reason I asked that is
because estate planning attorneys are
using the remote
notorized I wouldn't want them to put
them out of business by requiring them
to do something they aren't able to
do so it does both parts of the
bill chance the definition in both in
section three and section
10 any other question represent m f is
your hand still up or is it
no you ready to vote
so by yep so just for everybody's
information I'm at the fdic.gov
regulations
information Tech p in
HML it says signing and receiving
documents in signing a document the
sender uses his or her private key and
ver algorithm to create an encrypted
image of the original document that is
set with the clear text document to a
recipient receiving the document and
verifying the signature the recipient
uses the public portion of the center's
key together both parts of the C D are
used to verify the document was not
altered and that it originated from the
signer of the
docum go
on
was part of
what registered great incentives link to
that right
okay represent
Simpson um do can somebody I'm trying to
find it real quick but tell me when the
effective date for this bill would be
because I I if this is not universally
able to be done by um folks real quickly
I don't want to if this is eff you know
July
1st um then that makes me anxious
to expect the um compliance in such a
short amount of
time 180 days after
passage no
no effective dat
no
I says
uh part of it part of it says part of
the bill is part of section
two is uh
upon passage and part of it is 180 days
after
passage thank you Mr chair the the only
thing I would say is that
um this this this kind of language as
representative wer said was requested by
the registry of deeds because they have
real concerns around the security we're
dealing with real property and things of
this nature so we we want to make sure
that that's as secure as possible but we
we can't forget that we still have what
we've had for the last 300 years which
is the manual um mode of of of of doing
business as well that hasn't gone away
this is just an added option so we are
going to add it as an added option if
the registry of deeds has raised these
concerns um I think we can't lose sight
that we still have the old manual option
but we have to make this new option as
secure as possible so I'm going to
support the amendment even though some
people may not have the ability to do it
right
away represent
Simpson
okay any any other yes representing mcf
so thank you and I was I wanted to know
if if uh representative walor had had a
chance to run this any of the other
groups the bankers the The Mortgage
Bankers the real estate or the estate
attorneys to look at this
language I have
not thank
you one thing that uh I also point out
is we also have a bill which we retain
with regard to notarial services so if
we do need to fix something we do have
the ability to do that
so
uh there's no other discussion then I
guess you could call the role this is on
the amendment 1240
H
right okay on Amendment 1248 to Senate
Bill 134 changing the definition of
electronic signature representative plan
on the
amendment representative syvia
yes
representa
yes representative n yes representative
M
yes representative green
yes representative Kelly
yes representative Melvin
yes representative
Smith representative
Smith
yes representative bur
no representative
organ
Lorenzo
yes representative Chase
no representative
Kenny no representative
Langley
no representative MC
no representative P
yes representative
Simpson
yes Mr chairman
yes
14-6 you've adopted Amendment 4 12 112
12408 I have an amendment which is uh
was just sent out to you uh with
cooperation from my good friend
representative
mclan and it's Amendment
100h also the part two section 10 of the
bill
134 we received a letter from the
registers of Deeds objecting to to uh
part section 10 of the
bill and in discussing it with uh the
registers yesterday they indicated that
they were unhappy over the fact
that uh they have to deal with plats and
maps and surveys of a land
and uh and you just can't apply
electronic signatures to them and so
they wanted those to be accepted so this
amendment what it does it indicates that
a register Deeds shall accept for
reporting a tangible copy of an
electronic document other than a map
plat survey or plat of land as provided
in RSA
47818 and the registers indicated that
if we made that
change uh my register at least indicated
that they would be satisfied with the
bill and so I'll offer that Amendment if
there's a second to
it yeah
1300 is there a second to
[Music]
that any
discussion you ready to
vote
okay Mr Clark could you call the
rooll on amendment
13008 to sen Bill
134 representative client yes yes
representative Sy
yeses Alexander yes representative ner
yes representative M yes representative
green yes representative Kelly
yes representa Smith
yes representative bur yes
representative orgon yes
representative oreno yes representative
Chase yes representative Kenny yes
representative Langley
yes representative mcth yes
representative Paige yes representative
Simpson yes Mr chairman
yes
any other amendments on part two of
134 see we move on to part three
incarceration after a suspended
sentence
AMS seeing none move on to four civil
liability for damage to
highways I have an
amendment to
remove uh it's Amendment 1232
H basically it would remove
uh part four in its
entirety is there a second to
that I'll second
[Applause]
it
yeah this
um the reason I'm doing this as you may
recall the
testimony uh the testimony is that
basically this bill is already in the
budget and they put the bill in the
budget and put in a separate
bill and it's still in the budget the
only thing that they took out of the
bill when the budget went forward
was a provision that made uh the use of
estimates
retroactive and the question was whether
it was appropriate to make it
retroactive and actually whether it
would be enforcable if it was
retroactive and since the legislation is
already in the
budget and frankly I'm not in agreement
necessarily with making it
retroactive the testimony actually uh
was that
that they've already used in the past
they've used estimates for
damages uh and they consistently used it
except as I understand it the Attorney
General now has taken the position
that they don't think that they can
enforce
it and have elected not to enforce it so
long and the short since it's already in
the
budget with the exception of that one
provision I think we should just remove
the provision from this
bill MC Beth I would support you I think
that's the the reasonable way and the
fair way to move forward thank
you representative organ oh yes I agree
with you too and I
was this was sort of a gap for my
knowledge I didn't realize that they
don't um do the cost when calculating
the liability for depreciation which is
how it would be in the private sector
but um anyway I I think there a I think
this section is unnecessary and I don't
necessarily agree with what's in the
budget either but we don't need it here
so
thank thank
you any other
discussion then Mr clerk call a roll on
amendment 12328 to 134 dele part
four
representative yes representative syvia
yeses Alexander yes representative yes
representative M yes representative
green yes representative Kelly yes
representa yes representative Smith yes
B yes representative oron yes representa
dorenzo
yes Chase
yes representative Kenny yes
representative Langley yes
MC yes representative P yes
representative Simpson
yes
chairman
yes okay mov on to part
five that's structured
settlements there was discussion of an
amendment I don't know if anyone had
prepared an amendment for
this uh yes I believe I did but I'm
looking for
it
[Applause]
189 too much paperwork at the
moment uh here it
is uh Mr chair if I could be recognized
you may thank you you I would like to
move uh amendment number 11 189h and
speak to it okay and is there a second
to that the second seconded by
representative chase you may
speak uh thank you Mr chair uh in brief
uh those who are not familiar with
structured settlements those are
settlements uh where a person receives a
settlement but it's paid uh into their
pocket over time and some times that
individual cannot wait the amount of
time or chooses not to wait the amount
of time and wishes to sell that uh
settlement and get somewhat less money
but getting it uh immediately in hand
perfectly legal perfectly
understandable um the original bill in
in uh s SP
134 would require a Court's
approval uh in that it would require
an individual to show the court that he
or she had gone specifically to three or
so um potential buyers of the structured
settlement and uh go into the details of
those
negotiations uh the idea is that uh uh
the court wants to make sure that the
seller is not being taken advantage of
this
amendment um makes it somewhat less
owner
on the uh seller of the structured
settlement it says that that person can
negotiate the uh the terms and that that
person is advised to get uh competing
offers and whether the C and when the
court considers whether this structured
settlement sale is a good idea or not it
can take into
consideration whether the seller has in
fact uh talk to other people about um
this the terms of a sale so it protects
the privacy of the seller somewhat more
than the original bill but still
provides some uh method for the court to
make sure that the uh uh seller isn't
getting fleeced so to speak so uh that's
what this
amendment represen MC Beth
and any other
discussion seeing none I guess we're
ready to vote Mr
clerk Amendment
1189 to Senate Bill
134 representative M FL yes
representative syvia
yeser votes yes representative Alexander
yes representative yes representative
merer yes representative green yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Melvin yes representative
Smith yes
representative
yes Oregon
yes representative deeno
yes representative Chase yes
representative
Kenny
yes representative Lanley
yes representative MC
yes representative Pig
yes representative Simpson
yes chairman yes
to AG
group any other amendments to part
five part
six
establishing Law act representative syia
has an amendment if you would like to
recognize
me
yes representative
Soviet thank you Mr chairman uh I would
move uh Amendment
H and is that
seconded I'll
second by representative
Alexander and you want to speak to your
motion Mr chair that was representative
green that seconded not
me
sorry go ahead sorry
Alexander so U as I understand it the
collabortive law um currently is going
on and it works
well and it sounds like a great thing
it's good option for folks um but I
don't see because it is there and
working uh I don't see the necessity of
putting it into statute and therefore um
moving to remove
that section from the
bill any other
discussion I have to say that I think
that is uh pretty much true that you can
engage in collaborative law sort of
formalizes something that takes
place privately in any
event any other discussion represent MC
I'm really sorry to see this amendment
brought forward um you know I feel like
maybe the um you know we didn't have
enough education on this process um it's
really very different than a lot of the
different um the current alternative
dispute resolutions always having a
mental health professional at the table
to kind of point out when people start
picking on each other or no say the
triggers um and even when attorneys
start to maybe you know forgetting that
this is U going to be a collaborative
process so um I can't support the
amendment and I um I wish we could have
talked about it more before the
vote represent
bir
thank you Mr chair uh I can't support
the amendment either and um what
troubles me a bit is normally when we
get together and the stakeholders
involved in an issue have come to an
understanding about the value of a way
of approaching the issue unless there's
some real
problems uh that we see uh we tend to go
along with it we see that in landlord
tenant for instance you know if Elliot
Barry and Nick Norman come in and and
they're walking arm in arm we tend to
give that a lot of credibility it seems
to me and this isn't something that I've
ever practiced in with and I'm on my
first marriage so I don't know a whole
lot about it from a uh a consumer point
of view um the uh it seems to me that
the party
who are involved in this kind of process
not only seem to think it's a really
really good
process but they would they think
there's a benefit to having a certain
amount of structure in our statute
books and it seems to me unless there's
something really horrible about that
idea and I don't think there is um that
we perhaps should listen to those that
are actually living this dayt day and uh
take their word for it and then let them
do their their collaborative work uh in
a way that uh benefits Society you know
we have too many issues where we really
have significant disagreements between
various shareholders stakeholders you
know why sit there and pick one where
there really isn't a uh a quarrel about
whether there's some the people people
involved think there's a benefit to
having it in statute that it'll work
better it'll give some kind of referee
status to the rules and I I see only
gain and I don't see any harm in
exceeding to their wishes and having a
nice uh nice little statute to uh help
guide them through life thank
you any other questions or comments
1277 moving
part representative clain
yes representative siia
yes yes Alexander
yes yes yes representative mner yes
representative green
yes representative Kelly
yes representative Melvin yes
representative
Smith no representative B
noes Morgan
no representative De Lorenzo
no representative Chase
no represent Kenny no
representa
no M
no representative B
noes
no Mr chairman yes being 10 to
10 motion
fails section apparently stay the way it
is are there any other amendments on
section
six if not move on to section
seven this is with regard to various
matters involving probate
Administration I do have an amendment
which is uh Amendment one
121 and
[Music]
that that is uh would add what were the
provisions
in how House Bill 540 into this bill
into the section of the
bill is there a second to
that I'll second
it
made by representative
McLean
and so uh
as you uh we've discussed earlier we we
passed out of this
committee House Bill 540 we passed out
of the committee 21 to
nothing it was on the consent calendar
it left the house went over to the
Senate and then the Senate Judiciary
Committee heard it there were something
like 80 people who signed up in support
of the bill and nobody in
opposition and uh they heard testimony
from people only in favor and then the
Senate decided that they were going to
re re-refer the bill and uh for what
purpose I'm not sure but I think it
would be appropriate to add those
Provisions
into Senate
134 in the probate
section I know I've
heard
from
from Judge King that in fact this would
be good for the probate courts uh in
that to the extent that people can find
guidance from somebody without having to
have a formal guardianship it will save
time and effort on the part of the
courts and so I think it's an
appropriate Amendment
any other
[Music]
discussion yes represent Chase thank you
Mr chair sorry I'm trying to figure that
out I just want to um agree with you on
this is a very
important bill for many people this is
going to help um relieve a lot of stress
it's going to be help help people have a
responsibility for their own lives with
the guidance of others
uh it's really clearcut and clearly
there was not any
opposition and uh I thank you for adding
it in here and I am just thrilled to be
able to support that and I hope that the
whole committee will thank
you we have a
discussion Mr clerk want to call roll
amend 1218 to 134 adding house 540
language represent M yes representative
syvia yes represent yes
Alexander yes representative yes
representative M yes representative
green yes representative Kelly yes
representative yes representative Smith
yes
representative bur absolutely yes
representative organ
yes representative zenzo
yes representative Chase 100%
yes representative Kenny
yes representative lley
yes representative MC yes representative
Paige
yes representative
Simpson
yes
yes are there any other amendments on
part seven of the
B seeing none we move on to part eight
which is relative to school employee and
school volunteer criminal
background
are there any
amendments
[Music]
is this something that you sent out to
us I did not send it out I sent it to
all ask the intent of the amendment was
to remove this of the
bill but what sent me back do
that they
removed all but the study committee so I
sent it back to them to redraft it
yesterday so at this point in time you
don't have an amendment I have
one Mr chair I had the amendment back on
part one we want to go back and clean up
one while he looks for part eight or we
could do
that well what we'll do is well uh
representative wer has an amendment on
part eight but he's having some
difficulty locating it so what we'll do
is we'll go back to part one of Senate
Bill 134 now that the amendment is
available to deal
with so so go ahead representative CL
thank you Mr chair
um so um in light of our discussion
around 143 and the acceptance of uh
Senate amendments um Senator Carson had
offered an amendment on part one of uh
HB 134 which we did have to redraft um
so her original Amendment which would be
in everybody's email is amendment 1196 s
um the house version converted over is
um
135h so um the text is identical to um
1196 s it's just converted over um as as
a house Amendment so what part one of um
HB
134 does is it basically looks at the
law that we passed in
2016 that makes it illegal to point
laser pointers um at um at aircraft
obviously that's a very dangerous
situation uh so we passed that law um
however the unintended consequences of
passing that law were that um many
legitimate uses of lasers became illegal
uh they they kind of got caught up in it
so full disclosure um this part of uh
hb34 is very important to me it's very
important to my district and it's very
important to the city of Manchester um
vae is locating a new research facility
there and in the process of bringing
that in they realized that um a lot of
their work that they would be doing is
made illegal because of the current
nature of the law and so when they went
in and began investigating it basically
they they undid a can of worms there's
multiple legitimately uses that um are
made illegal by the current statute so
whether it's medical lasers whether it's
construction whether it's the use of
lasers uh for survey with
do um whether it's the the crash liar
that you have in your vehicle all of
that stuff is rendered um really illegal
under our current laser pointer statute
so what HB 134 did it it reached out to
various stakeholders to try to capture
as comprehensive a list of possible of
the legitimate uses of lasers so that
they could be Exempted of of the
existing law and um the amendment that
we have um which we just had converted
over from a senate version basically
what it does is it it extends the
prohibition element of um the law to
drones um because there was concern
raised that while you can't Point uh a
laser pointer at a vehicle or or an
airplane if you had a drone you could
put the laser pointer on a drone and
then by piloting the Drone you could aim
it at an airplane and that's kind of a
loophole so the amendment basically
addresses that loophole so as I said
this I I think it's it's important
legislation and I hope everybody on the
committee will uh join me in supporting
the amendment and and this part of the
bill representative
bur thank you Mr chair and hopefully
representative mlan can help me out here
um because I don't read the language of
the
amendment to do what I think you rightly
suggest might need to be done so my
question is uh I'm looking at the
crossed out language and then I'm
looking at the new language and the
crossed out language talks about
purposely or knowingly shining a laser
in an
aircraft uh with some other language but
basically that and it changes it it
drops out purposely or knowingly and
just has
knowingly and it still deals with
pointing a device at an
aircraft it seems to be that's all it's
dealing with not all those other
uh aspects that you say are
problematic it just makes something
that's extremely dangerous harder to
prosecute because instead of having
two
um uh mental Frameworks purposely
knowingly now the only thing illegal
would be
knowingly I mean you could purposely do
it and
not committing any sort of uh offense so
I'm wondering if you could explain why
this particular Amendment does all the
things that you say need to be done sure
um first of all um the original bill as
submitted was the the part that carved
out the exemption so if you want to go
and you want to examine that if you
forget the the amendment that was
offered but if you go back into the bill
itself and um you you'll see that in uh
section uh let me see what page is it
page two um line 22 this section shall
not prohibit aiming a laser beam or
pointing at a motor vehicle aircraft
vessel window structure or any person by
any of the following and it goes through
the list an authorized person in the
conduct of research government persons
authorized by the government Aerospace
contractors individual all are using
laser emergency signaling emergency
distress signal medical lasers so all of
those exemptions representative Burch
are not in the amendment um those are in
the the body of of the the main Bill
itself it's just having G through they
they wanted to clarify that you could
not use a drone and that's what the
amendment
does I'm not quarreling if if I may
follow up I'm not quarreling with with
the language in sb34 I understand the
purposes I'm just talking about what
this amendment that we have in our hands
is designed to do uh in terms of
changing uh
134 and it looks to me like it's only
making it uh uh harder to prosecute for
pointing a laser at an airplane and I'm
not sure why we should support that so
yes so
I I was quite with you for a minute but
as I read
this it says for any person in direct or
remote control right right right which
is different from what was
there right so so and I think it's the
remote control part that's more
important
than what I consider redundant purposely
or knowing right yeah and if I may Mr
Cher so yeah so maybe I misunderstood
your that's representative woler laid it
right on the head that the initial um
the initial bill from
2016 makes no provision for remote
control and so that so as we've learned
more about drones they wanted to make
sure that someone who is using a drone
under the old statute hey I'm not
pointing it at the the airplane the
Drone is pointing it at the airplane I
may be controlling that drone but
there's a stretch so this this was
sought to just clarify
that all
right okay
representative
IED
by yeah uh I'm got to call on the
committee Members
First representative
Simpson I I'm just trying to um maybe I
can add something to clarify this a
little bit this amendment deals with a
different a whole different part of the
statut than the part that's already in
the written up Bill so this this one
that is brought up right now deals with
the What's called the New Hampshire
Aeronautics act in statute 42 2 and so
it's just fixing um under the
prohibitions under the Aeronautics act
it's accounting for there being drones
now that might fly lasers so yes it does
change the language um from purposely
and knowingly to knowingly um and and
that's we can discuss that more but I I
just wanted to point out that it's it's
correcting a different statute but but
still doing it in part one of
this representative
Alexander um thank you Mr chair I think
um representative Simpson um did a great
job in clarifying that language change I
think like the the point of this is to
address unintended consequences from an
act that was put in place years ago um
in which Bae and other um industry and
other R&D agencies in this state are not
able to um do some secret military
contracts um based on certain things in
statute I think that that might be um
part of the reason why we should support
it representative
Sylvia I'll get back to the uh the heart
of the problem is that we have this
statute talking about uh laser pointing
devices
and uh the industry is now taking that
as any laser type uh
product and I don't think that was the
intention of the bill and when it I
shouldn't say Bill but when it was
originally brought back in 1999 and a
good Senator sat on sponsored this bill
uh at the time and uh with a a bad
description of what we're talking
about uh we have tremendous problems so
there's a fundamental underlying issue
that should be corrected uh frankly I
would repeal the whole thing for the
moment until we can actually get down to
what it is we're talking about so we're
all talking about the same thing at the
same time
representative czon did you have your
hand
up I couldn't get it to go back down
I'll work on
that there there is somebody who is an
attendee who may be able to contribute
and that's uh Mr kzy does anybody have
an objection if I were to call upon Mr
kzy to add an exp explanation and who
would Mr kzy be representing okay I
believe he is an industry representative
in support of the
bill I'm not going to stand in the way
of um I know it hasn't been our practice
to call on of Ed of education but
um I don't think lobbying if there's
educational information that's one thing
but representing a particular private
interest is something that makes me a
little nervous but I'm not going to
stand in the way well uh I think uh
we've taken the position that we are not
going to include people in the audience
for our executive session so I think
I'll I'll stand on that
so noting your your expressed
concerns okay so we have amendment in
front of us it's 1305
H any other
discussion I just like to mention
that represent Simpson said about the
Aeronautics act as opposed to being
63331 that
very IDE to have our
concer okay all right want to call a
roll this is on Amendment
okay Amendment 1305 to Senate
B
134 represent MCO
yes
representative representative Alexander
yes representative n yes representative
Mur yes representative green yes
representative Kelly
yeses Melvin
yes
yes representative
Oregon
yes representative orzo yes
representative Chase yes representative
Kenny
yes
Langley
yes representative MC
yeses Paige
yes representative
Simpson yes Mr chairman yes
Z okay any other amendments on part
one see none we move back to part eight
and representative wber did you find
your
Amendment actually I found
better uh if you
email I sent you Amendment 1276 about
before we get into this poter
business and liit
move part
eight I don't think that the Department
of Education wants to be involved in
this at
all so we should just not do it is there
a second to the
motion somebody chair was that
representative
Alexander okay
you want to say any more about your
Amendment no that's enough any
discussion there's no discussion we'll
just call the rooll this is on Amendment
1276 um M Mr chair I can't find
Amendment 1276
um I'm drowning of course in
papers uh and I apologize for not being
better at
juggling um is it very long could it
possibly be r or am I the only one who
is having
trouble I don't have
it it simply says delete section8
the entire section yes it just came
through an email yeah I couldn't find it
on my email but
[Music]
um the email is timestamp 256 today so
your your email your device may be
running behind or
something well you know over here in
Durham we're pretty slow yes
I can speak for
myself so uh are you ready to
vote Mr
cler Amendment 1276 removing part
section 8
of SD 134 representative main yes
representative s
yes yes representative Alexander yes
representative n yes representative M
yes representative green yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Melvin yes representative
Smith
no representative bur
no
representative
no Representative
deeno
no representative Chase
no Ken
noes Lang no representa MC
no representative p no representative
Simpson
no
yes
motion
fails was it 101
101 are there any other amendments
Party part
nine this is making an appropriation for
Health intervention training
programs Mr chairman um if I could just
make a comment
um I think this state is not doing what
we should be doing to address the issues
of
of the crisis in mental health the
crisis that's been
exacerbated by the pandemic but was
there before and will be there after I
do object to having an
appropriation
um inserted in the
middle
of one of these Omnibus bills and
although there is an FN it's 134
FN it is not going to go to a second
committee it will not be um
Incorporated uh in the workings of the
finance committee um to my knowledge it
was not considered uh by the finance
committee in the
um in the
Senate so I have a
problem but but I
haven't done anything about submitting
an an amendment and to do anything that
in any way made it seem that I did not
recognize the crisis that we're facing
would make me unhappy so thank you for
letting me speak and not accomplishing
anything
well yeah I I frankly I I can I can do
the same thing and
nothing but i i s of feel the same way
it's an appropriation for 210,000 I I
don't know why it's included in this
bill it seems to me that uh typically
what the Senate does is when they have
an appropriation like this they pass it
over there then they table it and then
they include it in their budget rather
than sending it over to us I've tried to
figure out why it is that they felt
compelled to do it in this particular
field
right but I frankly I didn't do an
amendment to take it out but I would be
just as happy as if if it
were representative
organ uh well this is a somewhat shaded
comment but perhaps they're anticipating
that uh the budget isn't going to be
passed on time as and that has happened
in several recent budget Cycles but they
felt this is important enough so that
the fiscal committee could authorize
expenditure of a funds because there's
always like piggy banks you can break
open of you know lapses you know funds
that have haven't been spent yet but um
I mean I share represent Smith and
resent Gordon and I two have not
introduced an amendment to take it out
but
um Mr chair could I I ask the
clerk I have two numbers here and I have
no idea I have an amendment 1223 and an
amendment
1273 I thought
that representative mlan had
introduced one of those but I guess I'm
wrong well
12 yeah 1223
um representative Smith was for 143 yeah
so
we yeah I know
it's F
this and actually 1273 is Reverend
Smith's Amendment which is relative to
Part 10 but we haven't gotten there yet
that's yeah I have trouble keeping these
134s and 143s and all these 1200 numbers
so straight myself so representative
Smith 1273 is titled amendment to
sb43 yeah oh yeah so I'm totally yeah
which we've already okay you're right
there being being no no amendment to
part nine we move on to Part
10 rather rather relative to employer
access to motor vehicle
records
have
am Mr
chair yes representative Smith
could
I have no right to ask what I'm going to
ask and you have every right to say
no but I think that some of us have been
confused
about amendments for sections nine and
10 I was wondering if you would consider
the
possibility of us
completing going through 11 and then I
don't know if there are any additions
and then instead of taking a final
vote
um delay a final vote until next Tuesday
and those of us who are slow and
confused and have mess things up might
have an
opportunity to
um no I guess that's not that doesn't
work that doesn't work I have to take
the responsibility for being confused
and let it go I'm sorry I take it
back
bir you're muted I was going to comment
on that proposal but since it's been
removed I have nothing to
add representative Alexander did you
have have your hand up I was comparing
to comment as well M Mr
chair okay section
uh section
10 which is relative to access to motor
vehicle records no
amendments no and section 11 relative to
authorization to grow industrial
hemp
yeah we have an amendment I
thought
what what's your amendment
number 1213
H and is there a second to
that I second
it seconded by representative
B yeah one two one three and you want to
speak to your Amendment representative
Simpson yes
um and I believe that Peter Bixby
representative Bixby wrote to us all as
well um this takes the opportunity to us
of us having a section on hemp to
correct a part of our statute that
doesn't match up with the rules that the
USDA has in um place right now
um
so I don't know if you all have it in
front of you it's very short if you'd
like me to read the change I'm happy
to what what it is short so why don't
you just read it so that we'll
understand hemp is an Agricultural
Product which may be grown as a crop
processed possessed and commercially
traded in New Hampshire any grower of
hemp shall be licensed by the
USDA and so what it does is it takes out
um proc processor and Commercial Trader
because the USDA doesn't um doesn't
license processors and Traders but we
had it in statute that they do so it
just leaves Growers because they do
license
growers
okay any
discussion Mr clerk want to call the
rooll 1238 to Senate bill
134 representative coin yes
representative syvia yes representa yes
representative Alexander yes
representative n yes representative ner
yes representative green yes
representative yes representative Melvin
yes representative Smith yes yes
representative yes representative
or un muted uh no I mean yes yes
yes representative
tzo yes representative Chase yes
representative
Kenny yes representative ly yes
representative yes
yes yes represent P yes representative
Simpson
yes Mr chairman yes the V is 20
zero okay are there any other amendments
to part
if not I think we have
completed our look at
134 we did
SE laser
po no that was that's 143
oh represent mlan you like to make a
motion yeah i' like to move um o to pass
as amended on uh SB
134 and is there a second from somebody
in the crowd
here seconded by representative
wer any
discussion uh Mr chair I wonder if um on
a belt and suspenders approach the clerk
might list all of the
amendments that um have
been
approved y clerk can list the Amendments
can't tell you what they all mean oh
didn't expect
that 1305 on part
one1
so okay so I have
one the has to find call sheet you know
V on am I can go off my Tally sheet yeah
I can go down I just have to
find so
wa wait did yeah but why don't we go if
you want I'll go down through them with
on on order if you want by
part
yeah uh it's 20 uh 1201 is
20 so part one we adopted Amendment
135h vote was 20 to
zero on part two we adopted Amendment
1240 H the vote was
14-6 on part three we
adopted uh Amendment
1300h and the vote was 20 to
Zer on uh part four we adopted Amendment
1232 the vote was 20 to
zero on part five we adopted
Amendment 11
189h vote was 20 to zero that's when we
were in a good
mood on uh
part uh six we adopted Amendment 2020 uh
one
121h and the vote was 20 to
zero on part eight we
adopted Amendment 1276
H uh actually we didn't adopt no not one
okay we defeated that and finally we
adopted on part 10 we adopted Amendment
1213 H and again the vote was 20 to
zero excuse me Mr chair um I saw maybe
one correction of what you just said uh
amendment
1300h was amendment to part two not to
part three we had two amendments for
part two is that correct according to
what I have
anyway yes you're you're correct
okay
yes and so we have we have a
motion to uh as OD to pass with those
amendments yes representative
syvia thank you Mr chair um I am going
to oppose the autop pass motion um this
bill contains far more bad than good uh
even though we did add a little extra
good to
it um if we go through and look at Laser
pointing devices we have no idea what
those uh were really talking about in
the statute that's pretty
bad um we have uh
certainly the the section on
collaborative law is not needed in this
statute
um the section for uh the appropriation
on mental health for the police training
standards um it seems to me that that
might very well be in conflict with some
of the training that already doing so I
have a problem with that um motor
vehicle records once again
we're um casting aside the privacy of uh
of people um these these uh it is quite
clear that there is a desire to
consolidate uh all of these data records
into one
company and uh probably resell it to
those who want
information and uh when we come to
Growing Industrial Hemp I think uh
Industrial Hemp is just a fine thing I
don't think that we should uh be giving
UNH a a cartel to uh hand out contracts
for growing so for those reasons I will
be voting
now thank you representative
Alexander um thank you Mr chair I do
want to Echo um representative Sylvia's
points I think there's a lot of good
things um in this bill but um I think
the bad outweighs the goods um I'm
particularly um against non-budget
Appropriations in the bill and um if we
had had a full committee I think things
would have been different but right now
I just am not comfortable voting for
this
bill okay any other
comments
concerns
see none I guess you call the
r
134 whatever it is six
amendments representative mcain
yes representative Sylvia
no
yes Alexander
no representative n yes yes
representative M yes representative
green
no representative Kelly
no representative Melvin
yes representative
Smith
bur
yes or
yes representative Delorenzo
yes representative Chase
yes representative Kenny
yes representa Langley
yes
yes representative Paige
yes representative Simpson
yes Mr chairman
yes
164 I guess it won't be on the consent
count okay so we're back toh Senate Bill
143 will there be minority for that yes
is there a Minority
Report
yes representative Soviet will do a
Minority Report
okay back to
143 and I guess we can deal with Section
one at this
point I think we were at a point
representative bir if I remember
correctly that you were offering an
amendment then comparing it
to the other amendment I note that the
amendment which was previously a senate
Amendment which was provided to us by
Senator Carson has been Rewritten
by Services it's exact same language
only now it's house Amendment 131
3 yes thank you um and just to make sure
we're procedurally correct I have moved
the
admission of uh 1267
H um I'd like to discuss it in in
comparison in contrast with the now
1313 um uh amendment I don't know if
that has to be moved in order to discuss
them both and how the chair would want
to
proceed
uh well I not sure that you can move
them both at the same time because you
can't vote on them both at the same time
so I think you can feel free to compare
it and to to the other Amendment and
we'll go from there all right
I do need I do need a second I and there
may have your motion may have been
seconded before but I it was I didn't
write it
down and um I will second it seconded by
representative Smith go go ahead
representative
bch thank you uh as this committee uh
more than uh well knows uh we have
wrestled with the uh uh issue of how to
provide better Council and better
representation to our children who get
involved in the Juvenile Justice System
um and uh that resulted in a bill that
uh went through uh house Judiciary I
think with only one or possibly two
objections and uh was tabled uh by the
house uh a month or so ago uh that was a
product of a lot of uh of by partisan
work and the work of experts within the
state and out of the state uh both uh um
legislators uh attorneys who have
experience in the family courts and
people whove collected data and the like
uh a lot of work went through it was a
result of a report that was uh done by a
National Organization that highlighted
uh issue areas that uh uh need need work
in this state um I'm spending a little
time on background because I I think
it's important the uh the
major uh recommendation from the report
was to create Specialists of lawyers
within the uh uh defense system that
would know uh exactly the best way and
the best practices to represent uh
youngsters in the juvenile justice
system as an alternative there are a
whole host of suggested uh um reforms of
the 40 or 50 suggested
reforms um we identified uh seven or
eight and uh those resulted in the
earlier Bill uh which has been tabled uh
since that time uh I've engaged in
conversation with uh people involved in
the in the field and that has resulted
in uh a
proposed uh Bill an amendment to the
Senate version the Senate has passed a
version of
um of Reform of council and juvenile
cases it's part of uh
sb43 uh I've looked at it with others
and um basically have filed uh 126 seven
uh also coming over is a uh an amendment
uh drafted uh by Senator Carson and put
forward today for administrative Reasons
by representative Gordon uh which is a
different approach so um the amendment
that I am urging passage at this time
1267 uh it does several things uh the
first and most notable thing it does is
that it uh provides earlier appointment
of council for
Indigent uh
children uh one difference between this
and what I'll call the senator Carson
bill um is that um The Proposal that I
am putting
forward uh allows the court at the
beginning when theti is filed to appoint
Council for all children appearing or to
to appear subject to a later
determination if necessary about whether
uh that child is financially eligible
for um uh State's uh
Services now the Carson bill on the
other hand requires and it it really
defeats the purpose re requires that the
court shall appoint Council for an
Indigent minor and that an Indigent
minor shall be a minor who satisfies the
court after appropriate inquiry um that
the minor financially unable to obtain
counsel this builds in a
delay it means a court can't get a
lawyer right off the bat which is the
whole purpose of this particular reform
because the court often will not have
the information in front of it
uh at the time the petition is filed to
determine
indigency so um unfortunately the Carson
uh
approach uh is far more problematic if
if you really want to get early
appointment of council to uh to
juveniles and to protect uh this the the
public wallet of course the court can
examine documents at any time and revise
the decisions as to whether Council
should be
approved uh
secondly um the next reform that hb12 67
does is that it um permits uh
representation of the child by
Council um
in proceedings that are related to the
delinquency proceeding and when Council
determines the participation is
necessary to perfect to uh effective
representation of the child and the
second part the appointment shall remain
in effect until the court no longer has
jurisdiction taking the second part
first such appointment shall remain in
effect in the court until the court no
longer has jurisdiction the uh uh the
Carson uh Bill uh does amendment does
not do
that the problem is that if count
council is representing a child it can
often go to appeal and further
proceedings and if you have to drop
council at the end of one proceeding and
get Council again and start over maybe a
different Council maybe the same Council
um that's not good
representation so hb1
1267 says that the appointment shall
remain in
effect until the court no longer has
jurisdiction so that will go through
appeals and the like there's no reason
that the Carson amendment gives for
making it harder to represent children
representation in other matters is a
simple thing it's hard to phrase it
right but the idea is is sometimes a I
may be representing a child in a
delinquency
proceeding and
the somebody may want to question the
child in a proceed a different
proceeding where the child May
incriminate himself or herself and that
child may need a lawyer to say don't
answer this question or don't answer
that question because it's going to
affect my representation of you in the
delinquency case and that's the purpose
of that it's not to have somebody
represent a kid in an unrelated uh IEP
case or an unrelated uh civil case or
anything like that it's just an
ancillary case where it may affect the
representation in juvenile in in the
juvenile delinquency matter that a
lawyer can still operate again the
Carson bill doesn't do that at all it
just ignores that subject matter and it
should not be
ignored the
uh a a as we all will recall there was a
debate over the issue issue of
representing children or children should
have lawyers at the time they are being
interrogated or questioned by law
enforcement or people acting in concert
with law enforcement that became an
issue at our last house hearing and uh I
remember my friend from uh Windam making
a pretty strong point about uh Miranda
rights and whether we should expand them
or not um there are two ways to approach
that one is one one way which I think is
the better
way is to say is to establish a bright
line rule that says children are
different than adults children are not
free to leave when they're being
questioned by adults and therefore they
should have protection that's a bright
line it's easy for police it's easy for
um school officials it's easy for people
to apply it's easy for courts to
apply that didn't uh do too well the
last time through
so in in respect for the arguments
presented by some I've done the in
1267 I've taken the more traditional
approach that we use in adult
court and basically said if a child is
in
custody and this is how we will
determine these factors make a
difference in determining whether the
child is in custody and we have that the
child's age of maturity the duration or
location the contact the uh existence of
a disability the presence of the
children's parents that the court needs
to take those into account make findings
of fact and then decide the custody
question so there is a huge compromise
in
1267 uh in terms of of the objection
that was raised in an earlier
time alas the
um the other Amendment the Carson
Amendment um skips the whole
subject it doesn't uh it doesn't go into
these factors during the discussion of
sb34 part2 authorization to grow
indust I miss that but I assume go
ahead all right
um so it's an important area that I
think it should be covered and the the
Carson Amendment just doesn't do that um
and then there's I think just a simple
mistake uh in the Carson Bill uh in in
my version the Juvenile and his parents
are not charged for
counil the problem of course is that
parents don't want to pay pay often for
the kids to be represented so they don't
get
represented the the
Carson
amendment has some conflicting language
in its
drafting in that it removes part but not
all of the reimbursement Provisions so
it leaves some reimbursement in but then
it also says that instead of the current
law this juvenile bill will uh for
services rendered will follow the
juvenile his entire or her entire life
which is not what the law is
now so on one hand it it it it would
seem to change the reimbursement
obligation in one section and then in
another section it says uh that uh it it
adds to the repayment obligation of
famili which is the exact opposite
direction that the experts talk about in
fact our Juvenile Justice System the
parents pay at pretty much every
stage and what we decided to do in the
working group was just talk about the
section on getting counsel the parents
still pay for counseling the parents
still pay for appeals the parents still
pay for this the parents still pay for
that you go through a whole
list we're just saying that it's
important enough for these kids to get
counil that they should be able to get
counsel and not have the parents say
well I I choose not to pay for that you
know just go in there and plead guilty
so there's some very significant details
that are different in these two
Provisions um all I can say is that I
urge uh the Judiciary Committee to to
respect back the work that has been done
on a bipartisan basis with experts um
and with uh lawyers with people in the
Judiciary people with the judicial
Council have worked hard and come up
with a
compromise uh piece of legislation which
is 1267 h i semi apologize for talking
as long as I did but this is an
important piece of legislation and I
want to just note in ending
uh that my good friend the
representative from Belmont earlier on a
different Bill uh used the phrase that
he was very paying attention to the due
process right of citizens that he felt
the due process rights of citizens were
really really important and I agree
that's why I voted for that amendment of
his um that's what this bill is about
this amendment is about you you have
very powerful government on one
side and you have citizens on the other
and not only do you have citizens on the
other you have the most vulnerable
citizens on the other side
children and the balance is way out of
whack and it's just fundamental if you
believe and there's many people here who
profess it pretty
loudly if you believe that the citizens
of this state have a
right to oppose the government when the
government has done wrong or the
government seeks to take their freedom
away then you have to give the citizen
the
tools to be able to do
that and one of the most effective tools
to do that is to have a
lawyer and that's a lot of what this
issue is are you going to support big
government or are you going to support
the children who need a voice so they
don't land up at a place like the cunu
center and have terrible things happen
so um uh I urge the strongest
consideration to uh 1267 thank you
representative
Alexander um thank you Mr chair um I
just have a question for uh my friend
from West Marland if he'll answer it for
me I'm sure he will representative bir
he'll do his best perfect um so this
this is a compromise to the bill that
was tabled um on the house floor it was
HB 188 is that correct yes okay that's
it thank you that's it oh
shs surprising
huh
well uh having sponsored the the other
bill I wouldn't I wouldn't consider it a
compromise only I don't when they
compromise generally you think of some
type of an agreement to come to a
compromise and I don't think that there
is any agreement that I'm aware of
but
so I I
first of all you should be aware that I
worked with representative Burch to put
together the bill in the first place and
I'm fully supportive of all the
provisions in the original
Bill and most importantly the section
which he just described at the very end
of his speech and that is kids need to
be
represented but there were other parts
to that bill that we all
know uh did not find favor and when we
were uh in Bedford
previously and so I'm willing to be what
I think is and I think that's what
Senator Carson was trying to be is
politically practical here and get what
is most important and what is most
important is representation for
kids and they do not have adequate
representation today granted and I think
everybody can get behind that and
support it and I think we can reach a
compromise on that but when you get into
issues with regard to use of statements
um then I think you're we're going to
get into the
same problem area that we were in in the
past as I understand uh and as I've read
Senator Carson's bill I don't a agree
entirely uh with my colleague from West
Morland and in that as I read the bill
it specifically provides that
appointment will be made
for of council to
juveniles no matter what it said upon
receipt of the petition the court shall
appoint councel for the
mining and that appointment shall occur
promptly in no event later than the time
when the summons is
issued
and uh and notice of the appointment
will be and so it is an immediate
appointment there is a provision in here
that that requires Court to make an
inquiry with regard to whether or not
the minor qualifies as an Indigent but
I'm not sure that that has to be or
needs to be at the initiation of the
process uh it seems to me that that
inquiry can be made at a later date and
in fact that happens all the time uh in
the court where the court appoints
attorneys to represent people only to
have them afterwards make a
determination as their
eligibility
uh the the the other parts of
it uh this includes a very important
part with regard to the the the
so-called Carson Amendment which I
sponsored at this point in time does
indicate that andc that it changes the
relationship between the attorneys and
the juveniles in that in the past
attorneys were disincentive to get
involved or more involved the case in
this particular case they've indicated
that uh payment uh isn't going to be
determined by a pre on a predetermined
free schedule and the Carson Amendment
provides for that and that and that is
extremely important it doesn't provide
for what was objectionable in the past
and that is
having attorneys get involved
in proceedings that are uh may be
related but uh but uh aren't directly
related to what may be taking place and
I understand that that's a shortcoming I
certainly would like to see attorneys
more involved in the preparations of
IEPs for kids because these kids have in
many
cases uh
some uh uh disabilities that should be
addressed in relationship to their
prosecution uh but as uh as we indicated
uh that found a jection on the floor of
the house before so long and the short
is I'm fully supportive of what
everything that representative Birch has
to say it's just I think the the
amendment I've offered is the the the
Practical alternative and it brings
about incr what the way I'd like to view
it is it brings about incremental change
it gets the very most important thing
done and that is getting representation
for kids uh and it gets it done and then
in the future we can deal with those
other parts to to make further
Improvement
so there anybody else would like to
comment
both of these
proposals problem I have
is represented that the
difficulties legal
qualifications St
partes I can't make out what he's saying
I'm
sorry
so the argument about how far
representation EXs bus with the
statement or
statement from from the
juvenile really is it's over my head in
legal
terms that's all I can say about that
it's over my head and I
know in 188
significant objection
the biggest I time the biggest
reason so it seems to me if we supp the
full house that is not a place should go
at this time and I
like that uh pointed out in the Caron
you pointed out in the Carson
amendment I don't really see a big
conflict
between
uh P part of it you just don't see that
and I think we make progress and and get
representation for every juvenile
immediately upon the following
petitions and and that's the most
important thing
so anybody else have
thoughts sure you
do want just vote uh I have to wait a
minute I have one member who needed to
have a bathroom break and frankly I I
need a bathroom
break can we
just take uh eight minutes and take a
break so I'm gonna call we're going to
be in recess for eight
[Music]
minutes
for
excuse
me a
bi
am 30 30 still lot I know and
I
oh
really feel
better
[Music]
we may need two more just for this Bel
that's amazing
well we talked about
that now just so you know we're not
muted
so just just as a procedural question Mr
chair
um did did somebody offer an amendment
or did we just have a
discussion am is 1313 it's on the floor
so the on the floor is 1313 no actually
oh no 1267 is on the floor on the floor
is 1267 okay just to clarify I know this
been because we've been talking about
folks so 1267 is on the floor Democrats
may want to look at their
[Laughter]
email which Democrats are not good at
doing 1267 yeah
yeah okay we'll call the house Judiciary
Committee back to
order thanks for everybody's patience I
know I feel
better we uh
we're at this point in time
discussing Amendment 1267 to part one of
Senate
Bill
143 and and is there any additional
discussion if not then we'll be voting
on that Amendment representative Wolford
do you want to call the
all on amendment number
12678 to Senate Bill
134 Representative mlan no
representative Sylvia
no no Alexander no
representative n no representative M no
representative green
no representative Kelly
no representative Melvin
no representative
Smith representative
Smith yes
B yes
represa
orgon you're
muted unmute unmute unmute
Tim amended
1267 how you
V
we you see you but not hear
you Tim raise your your thumb or lower
your thumb based on whether you're for
it or again
it make a noise so we can see it oh
there you go see it Tim thumbs up or
thumbs
down
not be able to hear
us hear
US Representative
orzo
yes representative Chase
yes representative
Kenny
yes representative Lang yes
representative
MC yes representative
paig yes representative
Simpson yes representative
Oregon I'm trying to get a hold of
you're I'm sorry excuse me chair I'm
trying to get a hold
of I think his headphones aren't
working
he okay yeah he sitting right there he
looks
fine did last oh there he is
okay he's trying to say
something we can't can't hear you
representative H can you raise your
thumb you can't hear us
either
oh well I know that's that's the
question that's right now I don't want I
know what he wants to
do V change the out
yeah can you hear
[Music]
us represent Horgan can
you thumbs
up okay all right and I vote no M
chairman votes no
pleas make
10 motion
fails as a
alternative I
would move Amendment 1313
H is there a
second second seconded by MC
Beth not
mcth
sorry I was getting a call back from the
number that was Tim Horgan's but it
anyway I'm I was yes representative
bur uh right speaking on the motion I
would just uh urge a vote against uh the
amendment thank
you any other
discussion this is the
last
okay clerk you can call a roll Amendment
133 yes representa syia
yes votes yes representative Alexander
yes
representative yes representative M yes
representative GRE
yes restive
Kelly yes representative Melvin yes
representative
Smith uh
no representative B
no representative
orgon
damn
represo no
representative Chase
no representative
Kenny
no representative Langley
no thumbs
down representative
MC
no representative Pig
no representative Simpson no
yes he Ved
no Mr chair
yes by
the
10 are there any amendments to section
one seeing
none are there any other amendments to
Senate Bill
143 okay just to go down through the
sections it appears that section one
will
remain as it was originally offered
section two has been amended
by
sections three
four five and six all appear to remain
as
submitted section seven was amended by
1272 the vote of 19
to1 Section 8 was amended by 1274 h oh
that wasn't amended sorry the motion
failed
and sections uh there was a motion that
failed with regard to section N9 section
10 which will remain the
same section 11 Remains the Same and
we've had no
um oh yeah I'm sorry but we've added a
section which is uh would be a new
section
which is 1280 H and on a vote of
18-2
somebody want to make a
motion I will move all to
pass as
amended does that represented Soviet it
was okay now I'd be happy to second
that
and
any
discussion
well
I I really wanted part nine out of this
bill unlike the part 10 and 134 which
deals with the motor vehicle records
which had prohibitions on sharing the
data I think part nine with sharing uh
the the the medical records um I I do
think that has the potential for
long-term
ramifications that we don't fully
understand but I'm conflicted because we
did add in the section on the Civil
asset
for so at this point in time I don't
know which way I'm G to go uh and I have
to vote first so well I I just want to
say I I share the I share the the the
same feelings because not just part nine
but part 10 I thought ought to come out
of the B and and and frankly at this
point in time I don't like part
one I I just don't think we learned
anything from our last go
around
so representative
Alexander um thank you Mr chair I just
um I think think that the Senate kind of
put us in a tough spot here um with
having to amend all these things in and
out and I think that um you know while
I'm happy with some things I do have to
agree that I just I don't want to I
don't want to encourage this um behavior
in the future so I'll be voting know as
well representative
Smith uh thank you um Mr chairman um I
agree with everything that
representative Alexander said accept um
his conclusion I think that these
Omnibus bills are an outrage I think
they interfere with the Democratic
process I think it makes it impossible
for us to end up with solid legislation
when the Senate did it last time I
objected and um un understood that there
might have been some problems that came
from um the pandemic um I must tell you
that I expected more from the president
of the Senate because I know of his
longstanding commitment to solid
legislation this is a disgrace and I
hope that we can do everything we can to
make sure this doesn't happen again but
I don't want to cut my nose off to spite
my face I don't want to vote no to make
a point
when that means that the good parts of
these bills don't go forward so with
great pain and great um dissatisfaction
in the corruption of the process I will
vote Yes but it certainly will not be
enthusiastically and I would ask the
chair if there were an opportunity to
make clear to the speaker how the
committee feels about these bills and
hope that the speaker might communicate
that
distress to the Senate leadership thank
you thank
you representative Chase did I see your
hand
up L yep can you hear me you can you did
and I'm sorry I'm going to just say this
because I'm not completely understanding
it I think it has to do with the
amendment that I know we already voted
on for um Carson's and your bill which
is now
1267 is there any way of possibly taking
out section five of that with the
um the cost fees or where it doesn't
matter okay never
mind I'm so sorry I'm I'm okay because
we have voted on it we cannot change it
as I think we're we have a motion
pending right now Bill itself okay it
doesn't matter since another NE
amendment was okay never mind I'm
sorry just felt like saying hello hi
everybody it's that Florida heat yeah I
just saw a rocket launch by the
way oh good well during our break yeah
anybody else want to weigh in on this
vote
if not Mr clerk you need to take the
rule this is on the motion of ought to
pass as
amended to pass we've already we've got
one
134 representative M 14 143
143 we need into the
day3 pass amended reluctantly
no
yes represent Alexander
no represent Mur
no representa re
no representative Kelly
yes representative Melvin
no representative
Smith
yes representative
bur yes
representative oron I'm back
yes representative Reno
yes representative Chase
yes representative
Kenny
yes
yesc
yes page
yes
Simpson
yes Mr
chairman one I 13
SES what was that again 13
to7 guess that's not
consent
[Music]
today Mr clerk you all set I'm all
set all set somebody going to do a
minority work for that yeah is there
going to be a Minority
Report Mr chair I'll do it I'll do it if
you'd like that'd be
great okay Alexander do The Minority
Report
we have uh next week we have uh actually
one other one other piece of business
perhaps and just while we're here we
heard Senate Bill
morning on landl Lord
tenant there was absolutely no objection
to that and I do have it scheduled for
next week but I didn't know whether or
not you wanted to get it out of the way
today if everybody was in agreement with
that y yes that's
fine and would somebody like to make
that
motion
um I
so was were you going to move
representative D Lorenzo I was GNA move
a to pass okay Resa D Lorenzo moves out
to
pass and seconded by representative
Smith well I I it would be lovely I
think if one of our colleagues from the
other side of the aisle would like to
Second
it somebody like to Second it on I'll
second it representative mlan said he'd
second
it okay any
discuss represent you Lorenzo do you
want to speak to your motion at all yeah
yes um I do thank you Mr chair I think
it's a good bill I think it is a really
um a bill that helps landlords and
tenants and it keeps people in their
homes um and so I I I can't see any
element of this bill that does not work
for all that's it thank you
126 and the motion is
pass okay any other
discussion apologize for the technical
difficulties B go ahead Bill
126 pass
representative yes representative syia
yes yes represent Alexander
yes
yes me no
Kelly you're muted Kelly
yes representative Melvin yes
representative
Smith yes yes represent bir
yes
[Music]
yes representative Deo
yes representative Chase yes
representative Kenny yes representative
Lang
yeses
yes
yes repres Simpson
yes Mr
yes on 20 vote
wow made a recommendation about to pass
Senate
126 will this go on the consent
calendar unless there's an objection
from
anyone done deal
and so next next week um we have one
bill to here that's I think it's Senate
Bill 96 in the
morning and then we're scheduled for an
executive session it was going to be
on
125 uh excuse me it was going to be on
95 and
126 but we just did 126 so we have
scheduled and we're hearing 96 in the
morning so maybe if everything went well
maybe we could exec on 96 as well as
long as there's not a great need for
amendments and then get our work done
next week we'll try to do that there may
be an amendment coming in on 96 and a
fair number of people may be talking
about it what a surprise Mr chair I have
I have plans for amendments for 96 as
well okay maybe we'll delay
that okay well there's no other business
thank you everybody for the long
day thank you Mr chair you sorry for the
disrup thank you thanks